Listener, this is Will. If you're hearing this, it means that something has happened which I feared for a long time. This might be the last time you ever hear my voice and I know some of you are celebrating it then. But just know, just know that I loved every single one of you the same. You all mean so much more to me. And because, because I'm gone, just know that Sean and Jason don't give a shit about you. They literally said, I said to both of them, I said, do you guys know how much our listener means? And they said, I don't give two fucks about our listener. Jason said that as he slammed the
听众朋友们，我是威尔。如果你听到了这段话，那就意味着发生了一件我一直以来非常害怕的事。这可能是我留给你们的最后的声音了，我知道你们当中有些人听到这里甚至会开香槟庆祝。但请你们知道，请务必知道，我对你们每个人的爱都是一样深厚的。你们对我而言意义非凡。正因为，正因为我不在了，你们要知道肖恩和杰森根本不在乎你们。他们亲口说过的，我当时对他们俩说，我说，你们知道我们的听众对我们有多重要吗？结果他们说，我才他妈不在乎我们的听众呢。杰森一边说着，一边砰地关上了他那辆欧洲车的
door on his European car. Anyway, I love you and welcome to an all new smart list. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. We had our family reunion. I didn't ask. Okay, let's move on. Who's ready with their coffee chat? Let's hear it. How was it? I did it. I just got back.
车门。总之，我爱你们，欢迎收听全新一期的“聪明糊涂心”。聪。明。糊。涂。心。聪。明。糊。涂。心。我们刚开了家庭聚会。我没问。好吧，我们继续。谁准备好分享咖啡时间了？说来听听。感觉怎么样？我刚回来。
Did anybody drink into a fight? No, no, no, no, nobody fought. It was great. It was fantastic. It was lovely. Jay, I called the coffee shop and they were like, I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop.
有人喝到打起来吗？没有，没有，没有，没有人打架。棒极了。太美妙了。非常温馨。杰，我给咖啡馆打了电话，他们说，我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。
I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. I'm going to go to the coffee shop. Who's ready with their coffee chat? Let's hear it. How was it? Any fights? I just got back. Did anybody drink into a fight? No, no, no, no, nobody fought. It was great, it was fantastic. It was lovely.
我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。我要去咖啡馆。谁准备好分享咖啡时间了？说来听听。感觉怎么样？有人打架吗？我刚回来。有人喝到打起来吗？没有，没有，没有，没有人打架。棒极了，太美妙了。非常温馨。
Jay, I called in, I got to say hi. I got to meet some of the family. Got to meet his niece and her boyfriend. What do you mean you called in? I don't understand. FaceTime. I FaceTime with Sean. We keep in touch and say hello.
杰，我连线进去了，我得去打个招呼。我有幸见到了部分家人。见到了他侄女和她男朋友。你什么意思，你连线进去了？我不明白。FaceTime。我跟肖恩FaceTime了。我们一直保持联系，打个招呼。
Yeah, you really do. This is how normal human beings. We talk about this sometimes. What is it? Is it like a nightly thing? I've just been sort of teasing, but now I'm actually, I'm in my FIFIs about it. You guys talk every night?
对，你们可真会这样。正常人类就是这么做的。我们有时也会聊到这个。是什么情况？这就像是每晚例行公事吗？我本来只是开个玩笑，但现在我真的，我为此感到有点小情绪了。你们每天晚上都聊天？
No. No. You do with Josh. Fucking Josh Shotlin gets you on a FaceTime every goddamn day. Who's Josh? Just this guy who likes to talk on his FaceTime with Will on his couch without his top on.
没有。没有。你跟乔希倒是天天聊。他妈的乔希·肖特林每天都要用FaceTime找你，天天如此。乔希是谁？就是那个喜欢光着膀子在沙发上跟威尔视频的家伙。
That's true. Yeah, and he frames himself just below the T's. That's true. Just below the T's. Yeah, it's weird. Is he still on plastic on his couch? No. Just when he talks to you.
确实。对，而且他镜头只截到胸肌以下。没错。刚好在胸肌下面。对，挺诡异的。他沙发上还包着塑料保护膜吗？没有。只有跟你视频时才包。
Yeah, the only time he takes a break when the guy comes, the food delivery comes, he's always like, one second. Yeah, so wait, so how often are you guys FaceTiming? A couple times a week maybe. I was like, one second. Yeah, so wait, so how often are you guys FaceTiming? Couple times a week maybe. Higher. Higher while you lie to me. Is it every other night? No.
对，他唯一暂停的时候就是送外卖的来了，他总是说，等一下。好吧，等等，那你们多久用FaceTime连线一次？也许一周几次吧。我当时说，等一下。好吧，等等，那你们多久用FaceTime连线一次？也许一周几次吧。频率更高。你骗我，频率更高。是不是隔晚一次？没有。
So another lie, you go super low or super high, they're lying, lying. But this is fun for you guys, you guys stay in contact as your best friends And you'd like to keep up on each other's lives and call into reunions and stuff like that You know I'm fucking sitting here doing nothing But I know what we're gonna do is then we're gonna we're gonna take the clip out of you for the last 10 seconds Complaining about it. We're gonna take your your facial expression and your tone, and then we're gonna ask you
又是一个谎话，你要么说得极低，要么说得极高，他们就是在撒谎，满嘴谎言。不过这倒挺有意思的，你们作为好朋友保持联系，喜欢了解彼此的生活，还会连线参加聚会什么的。你知道我他妈就坐在这里无所事事。但我知道接下来会发生什么，那就是我们会剪辑出你最后10秒钟抱怨的片段。我们会截取你的面部表情和语气，然后我们会问你
Would you call that guy Yeah Well, maybe just not face time so you don't have to see the heavy brow I've I faced them with you the last time I faced them with you last week and you were you were on it Do we want to get into this you were on a floaty? Oh, yeah Time yeah, you know, I've remembered I have a pool. Yeah, you know, I can enjoy Yeah, he was floating. No, no can enjoy. Sean, he was floating. No, no, no, no, how about this? Two weeks ago, when I went to visit him,
你会怎么形容那个家伙？对。好吧，也许就是少用FaceTime，免得你看到那一脸的愁容。我上周才刚跟你FaceTime过，你当时，你当时正在——我们要聊这个吗？你当时正躺在浮排上？哦，对。时间，对，你知道的，我记起来我有个泳池。对，你知道的，我可以享受——对，他当时正漂在水上。不，不，我能享受。肖恩，他当时在漂。不，不，不，不，这样吧？两周前，当我去看望他的时候，
he was on a floaty in the pool at his house, ordering sushi from the pool. Yeah. I like to live the good life every couple of days, you know? Way to go, JB. We're trying to get people, dissuade people from the opinion that Hollywood types are a bunch of dicks, total douchebags.
他正躺自家泳池的浮排上，直接在泳池里点寿司外卖。对，我每隔几天就喜欢过点好日子，你知道的？干得好，JB。我们正努力纠正世人的偏见，打消人们认为好莱坞这群人全是一群混蛋、十足的人渣的看法。
And you just like rode it. Wait, this is a public pool. I'm down at the Y. This is a public pool. But in Jason's defense, he picked up, he drove to pick up the sushi. No kidding. Yeah. Look at you, gross. I wanted to put it in my face quicker than Uber could bring me. Where did you, you didn't go to the place in Beverly Glen, did you?
而你直接把它划过去了。等等，这是公共泳池。我在基督教青年会（YMCA）呢。这是公共泳池。不过说句公道话，杰森是自己开车去取寿司的。开玩笑吧。对。看看你，真恶心。我只想快点把它塞进嘴里，不想等优步送来。你去了哪家？你没去贝弗利格伦那家吧？
Uh, no, no. This was a sugar fish special. Yummy. I love that place. They make a nice box down there. They do. I do. Is it me or does sushi delivery now, they've kind of upped things.
呃，没有，没有。这是“糖鱼”（Sugarfish）的特选寿司。美味。我太喜欢那家店了。他们在那儿打包的盒子很精致。确实。我是吗？还是说现在寿司外卖的档次真的提升了。
Yeah, it used to be, it didn't travel well. Right, a real slapdash thing with a sweaty, plastic see-through box. Now it's a paper thing that's got nice printing and graphics. Yeah, it's got little sections on it. Yeah. All right, let's get to the guest. JB, before you get to your, I know you're anxious.
对，以前的外卖，根本经不起配送。没错，那种半透明的塑料盒上还带着汗水，十分草率。现在都是纸盒了，上面还有漂亮的印刷和图案。对，里面还有精细的小格子。对。好了，我们来请出嘉宾吧。JB，在你发表——我知道你很急。
Yeah. We got, let's remind our listener. Our thing afterwards. For our thing afterwards to stick around and listen to, right Sean? Yes, it's called Goal-less. It's a new show from Smartless Media, our little podcast company. And I'm going to tell you all about it at the end of the episode, so please stick around.
对。我们得，提醒一下我们的听众。关于我们接下来的那个节目。就是接下来的那个节目，大家要留下来听听，对吧，肖恩？是的，它叫“Goal-less”。这是Smartless媒体公司推出的一档新节目，也是我们自己的小播客公司。节目最后我会向大家详细介绍，所以请大家务必留到最后。
Yeah. All right, tighten up guest. Here we go. Guys, I don't know if you like acting talent. A lot of people do. For some reason, the three of us seem allergic to it being anywhere near our work. But this guy has got a lot of people do. For some reason, the three of us seem allergic to it being anywhere near our work, but this guy has got a lot of it. And if we're nice to him, maybe he'll share some.
好的。嘉宾，打起精神来。我们开始吧。伙计们，我不知道你们是否喜欢演技派。很多人都喜欢。出于某种原因，我们三个似乎对让这种东西靠近我们的工作产生了排斥反应。但这家伙——很多人都喜欢。出于某种原因，我们三个似乎对让这种东西靠近我们的工作产生了排斥反应，但这家伙身上可有满满的演技。如果我们对他好一点，说不定他会分给我们一些。
He could also lend us a few of his numerous nominations and wins for his work, which he's been, well, he's been, oh God, still rolling? Which he's received well-deserved recognition for from all over the world. Sean, you're going to want to discuss within the whimsy and the wonder of projects such as The Chronicles of Narnia, X-Men, Children of Dune.
他还可以借给我们几个他凭作品获得的无数提名和奖项，为此他一直——哦天呐，还在录吗？为此他从世界各地赢得了实至名归的认可。肖恩，你肯定会想讨论那些充满奇思妙想和奇幻色彩的项目，比如《纳尼亚传奇》《X战警》《沙丘之子》。
While Will, you'll be more interested in the subjects covered in titles such as Shameless, Wanted, Filth, and ultimately Atonement. He's a Scottish treasure, a Celtic FC diehard, and a recovering video game addict. Please show some compassion and hospitality to the one and only James McAvoy. James!
至于威尔，你可能会对以下作品所涉及的主题更感兴趣，比如《无耻之徒》《通缉令》《污垢》，以及最终的《赎罪》。他是苏格兰的国宝，凯尔特人队的死忠粉，以及正在戒除网瘾的网瘾患者。请对独一无二的詹姆斯·麦卡沃伊展现出你们的同情心和好客之道。詹姆斯！
Hey guys, what's going on? How you doing? Look at him. I'm a massive, massive fan. Yeah, pump the brakes. We're going to get to X-Men and things like that. And Split is one of my favorite movies, one of the best performances I've ever seen anybody ever.
嘿，伙计们，最近怎么样？你们好吗？看看他。我是他的超级超级粉丝。行了，收收吧。我们等下会聊到《X战警》之类的作品。《分裂》是我最喜欢的电影之一，也是我见过任何人奉献出的最精彩的表演之一。
Thank you so much. You played like 75 characters in that. Let's start with Hi. Let's start with Hi, okay? Let's just start with Hi. How are you guys? Nice to meet you. I've always wanted to meet you.
非常感谢。你在里面演了大概75个角色。我们先从“嗨”开始吧。我们从“嗨”开始，好吗？就从“嗨”开始。你们好吗？很高兴见到你们。我一直想见你们。
Don't choke the puppy, Sean. Yeah. Hey, Will, do you have anything you'd like to say about Celtic FC or do they mess around with your Liverpool fans? No, they don't because they play in a different league. First of all. Don't be shitty.
别把小狗勒死了，肖恩。对。嘿，威尔，关于凯尔特人队，你有什么想说的吗？还是说他们会跟你们利物浦球迷过不去？不，他们不会，因为他们踢的是不同的联赛。首先。别这么扫兴。
So if I were a Rangers fan, then we'd have more of an issue. But I will say one of my favorite players plays for Liverpool, who happens to be a Scott, Andy Robertson, who I just adore. Sure. He's amazing. And also one of the greatest Liverpool players of all time,
所以如果我是流浪者队的球迷，那我们可能还会有更多矛盾。不过我得说，我最喜欢的球员之一就在利物浦踢球，而且他碰巧是个苏格兰人，安迪·罗伯逊，我真的超级喜欢他。确实。他太棒了。而且他还是利物浦有史以来最伟大的球员之一，
Kenny Dalglish, not to mention Graeme Soonis, but Kenny Dalglish was also a massive, massive, like icon for Celtic as well. So Kenny Dalglish, I had the pleasure last year, I bored these guys when I went on my various trips over to Liverpool, and I got to sit with Kenny Dalglish. I got to sit with him. First of all, the last game I went to,
肯尼·达格利什，更不用说格雷姆·索内斯了，但肯尼·达格利什同样也是凯尔特人队巨大无比的偶像。所以肯尼·达格利什，去年我有幸——我去利物浦的各种旅行中烦过这几位——我得以和肯尼·达格利什坐在一起。我有幸和他坐在一起。首先，我去看的最后一场比赛，
when I went to Jurgen's second last game, he was behind me with his wife. Well, he first of all the last game I went to when I went to Jurgen second last game He was behind me with his wife JB you watch your manners Just working on fake snoring that's all You are honestly you're about to make you're about to make millions of enemies right now. No Fucking respect to sir Kenny dog leash. The stand opposite says the Sir Kenneth Doglish stand at Liverpool and he's sitting there looking at his own stand.
当我去克洛普倒数第二场比赛的时候，他和妻子就坐在我身后。好吧，首先我去看的最后一场比赛，当我去克洛普倒数第二场比赛的时候，他和妻子就坐在我身后。JB，注意你的礼貌。我只是在假装打呼噜，仅此而已。老实说，你这是要——你这是要瞬间树敌成千上万啊。没有。对爵爷肯尼·达格利什保持绝对的尊重。利物浦球场对面那个看台就叫“肯尼斯·达格利什爵士看台”，他就坐在那儿看着以自己名字命名的看台。
He's a fucking icon, dude. Yeah, I know, he's brilliant. He's really, really amazing. He's famously dour, but I was lucky enough to be managed by him at a charity football event once. And I spent like three or four days with him during this time. Sean was managed by a dog leash at one point
他绝对是个传奇人物，老兄。对，我知道，他太棒了。他真的非常了不起。他以严肃冷峻闻名，但有一次我有幸在一个慈善足球赛上接受他的管理。在那期间我和他一起度过了大约三四天。肖恩，你职业生涯的某个阶段也曾
in your career. Right, Sean? Yeah, just a couple tugs and I'm yours. Oh, cute. I love an easy way. Oh, God. I love an easy way. Oh, God. James, I'm so sorry. Good night, everybody. James, thanks for joining us.
接受过达格利什的管理。对吧，肖恩？对，只要拉扯两下，我就是你的人了。哦，好可爱。我就喜欢这么简单粗暴的。哦，天呐。我就喜欢这么简单粗暴的。哦，天呐。詹姆斯，真的很抱歉。大家晚安。詹姆斯，谢谢你加入我们。
It's been great, guys. Thanks very much. This has been like the real middle point of my career. Thank you. Fucking fuck! Does anybody call you Jim or Jimmy? Yeah, yeah. I don't get Jim too much. There's one guy who brilliantly is also... Not brilliantly, he is Scottish, but he rather brilliantly calls me...
太棒了，伙计们。非常感谢。这简直算是我职业生涯真正的中点。谢谢。他妈的操！有人叫你吉姆（Jim）或吉米（Jimmy）吗？会，会。叫我吉姆的不多。有一个家伙，绝妙的是，他也——也不是绝妙，他是苏格兰人，但他非常巧妙地叫我——
He's called Jocky and he calls me Jocky. And a couple of my mates call me Jimmy Floyd. Wait, Jocky? Wait, where does Jocky come from? I don't know where Jocky comes from. Jock is also rhyming slang for Scottish person because it's Sweat Sock Jocky come from? I don't know where Jocky comes from. Jock is also rhyming slang for Scottish person because it's sweaty sock jock. Oh really?
他叫乔基（Jocky），他叫我乔基。我的几个哥们儿叫我吉米·弗洛伊德。等等，乔基？等等，乔基是怎么来的？我不知道乔基是怎么来的。Jock也是苏格兰人的押韵俚语，因为它是sweaty sock（流汗的袜子）——乔基是怎么来的？我不知道乔基是怎么来的。Jock也是苏格兰人的押韵俚语，因为它是sweaty sock jock（流汗袜苏格兰人）。哦，真的吗？
Go back to sweaty sock. Sweaty sock. If you're a sweaty, if you're a sweaty sock in England, if you're like a cockney and you're referring to Scottish people, you say sweaty sock because it rhymes with jock. So, but he was called Jocky and for some reason he would call me Jocky, but then most of my mates would call me Jimmy Floyd. How about that? Where does that come from?
回到流汗袜。流汗袜。在英格兰，如果你是一个流汗袜，如果你是个伦敦东区人（cockney），然后你指代苏格兰人，你就会说“流汗袜”，因为它跟jock押韵。所以，但他叫乔基，出于某种原因他会叫我乔基，但我的大部分哥们儿会叫我吉米·弗洛伊德。那这个呢？这个是怎么来的？
Wait, where does Floyd come from? Two of my favorite football players, one of them was Henrik Larsson, his name didn't become anything to do with mine. The other one was Jimmy Floyd Hasselbank and so they used to call me Jimmy and then they started calling me Jimmy Floyd. And then they used to call me Jimmy, and then they started calling me Jimmy Floyd. And then they just dropped the Jimmy, and most of them just called me Floyd. And then I've got one mate who's from Newcastle who calls me Jimmy Flau.
等等，弗洛伊德是怎么来的？我最喜欢的两个足球运动员，其中一个是亨里克·拉松，他的名字跟我没有任何关系。另一个是吉米·弗洛伊德·哈塞尔巴。所以他们以前叫我吉米，后来开始叫我吉米·弗洛伊德。然后他们以前叫我吉米，后来开始叫我吉米·弗洛伊德。再后来他们直接把吉米省掉了，大多数人直接叫我弗洛伊德。然后我还有一个纽卡斯尔出身的哥们儿叫我吉米·弗劳。
Jimmy Flau. Jimmy Flau. Nobody calls me shit. How come, I don't have a nickname, do I? Well, listen, by the end of this podcast, we're going to have a nickname for you. Crank Uncle Grumps. Uncle Hansy. How come I don't have a nickname, do I? Well, listen, by the end of this podcast, we're going to have a nickname for you. Frank Uncle Grumps.
吉米·弗劳。吉米·弗劳。没人叫我这破名字。怎么回事，我没有绰号，对吧？听着，到这期播客结束时，我们肯定会给你起个绰号的。暴躁古怪大叔。色老头叔叔。怎么回事，我没有绰号，对吧？听着，到这期播客结束时，我们肯定会给你起个绰号的。弗兰克，暴躁古怪大叔。
Uncle Hansi. Uncle Hansi. Bitch slap. Wait, James, I have a feeling by the end of this interview, we're going to have nicknames for each other. I feel like we've got a real quick connection right here. Not with the other guys, just me. James McAvoy, what beverage are you enjoying right now?
色老头叔叔。色老头叔叔。碧池耳光。等等，詹姆斯，我有种感觉，这次访谈结束时，我们都会给彼此起外号了。我觉得我们俩之间有一种非常默契的瞬间连接。不是跟其他人，就只有我和你。詹姆斯·麦卡沃伊，你现在在喝什么饮料？
Because it's got a lot of ice in it, which I enjoy. It's soda water and lime right now. I did have a Cosmo right before we started this. No you did not, did you? Yeah I did, I had a Cosmo. I love that, where are you right now? I'm in my basement. But where?
因为里面有很多冰，我挺喜欢的。我现在喝的是苏打水加青柠。开始录之前我确实喝了一杯柯斯摩（Cosmo）。你才没有，真的吗？对，我喝了，我喝了一杯柯斯摩。我喜欢这个，你现在在哪儿？我在我的地下室里。但在哪儿？
I ran back here, in North London. In North London. Fantastic. Wow, it looks fancy. I want London. In North London. Fantastic. Wow, it looks fancy. I want to live in North London. I know, look at him, he's just having a little cosmo with him. Nice painted wall behind him with a good iron window.
我跑回这里了，在伦敦北部。在伦敦北部。太棒了。哇，看起来很高级。我想在伦敦——在伦敦北部。太棒了。哇，看起来很高级。我也想住在伦敦北部。你看他，正一边喝着小柯斯摩呢。他身后有粉刷得很漂亮的墙，还有一扇漂亮的铁窗。
Like a Hawaiian shirt on or something. This is my basement, this is my little man cave. I don't like that term, but it is like my little place that I get to come and be. And I've got a little sort of wanker gem over there. And I've got a TV in front of me. We're going to let you rephrase that. It's where I get stronger as a wanker. I really work on my technique.
还穿着夏威夷衫什么的。这是我的地下室，这是我的小男人洞穴。我不太喜欢这个词，但它确实是我可以来这里待着的小地方。那边有个我专属的、像个手冲狂人的小健身房。我面前还有一台电视。我们允许你重新组织一下语言。这是我变得更强壮的手冲狂人基地。我真的有在精进我的技术。
I like try and make it harder for myself sometimes. I put weights on my hand. Sure. You know, I would say that you operate this very unique space where you are such a great actor and you've, but you've managed to kind of create, you kind of stay out of any category. You're very unique.
我有时会故意给自己增加难度。我在手上绑上哑铃。当然。你知道的，我觉得你处于一个非常独特的空间里，你是一位如此优秀的演员，而且你设法创造了——你设法避开了任何既定门类。你非常独特。
Like you've just, I don't know, you've got this kind of patina about you that's very fucking, I remember the first time I was like, wow, this guy's amazing. I was watching, it was Last King of Scotland, which was years ago, I know. Fantastic.
就像你——我不知道，你身上有一种非常他妈的——我记得第一次我觉得“哇，这家伙太厉害了”的时候，我正在看《末代独裁》，那是多年前的事了，我懂。太棒了。
Fucking phenomenal film, dude. And I was like, who was Last King of Scotland, which was years ago, I know. Fantastic. Fucking phenomenal film, dude. And I was like, who the fuck is this guy? Yeah. This guy's a fuck it, right? And then you've just, every time I see you, you kind of carve out these different little niches for yourself and you stay at, I don't know, you've got your own lane that you've created,
他妈的现象级电影，老兄。当时我就想，谁是——《末代独裁》，那是多年前的事了，我懂。太棒了。他妈的现象级电影，老兄。当时我就想，这他妈是谁啊？对。这家伙是个狠角色，对吧？然后你——每次我看到你，你都能为自己开辟出各种不同的小天地，你保持着——我不知道，你创造了属于你自己的赛道，
which is really admirable, because a lot of people kind of go into a kind of a cookie cutter thing. Is that something you're conscious of you're constantly going fuck I want to do something a little bit different I want to be over here I want to go over here yeah no definitely I'm look a hundred percent I I've been really lucky not to just have to play the same kind of thing again and again again although latterly I have been looking at my fucking career. And, literally, I've been... I'm going to want you to lay down right through this part and just elevate your head.
这真的令人钦佩，因为很多人都会陷入那种千篇一律的套路中。这是你会有意识去做的吗？你是否不断地在想：操，我想做点不一样的东西，我想去那边，我想去这边？对，绝对的。听着，百分之百，我真的很幸运，不用一遍又一遍地只去演同一种类型的东西，尽管最近我一直在审视我他妈的职业生涯。而且，说实话，我一直在——我等会儿想让你在这段期间躺下来，然后把头抬高一点。
And just tell us what you're feeling. Well, you know, I am in my wanker gym, which is where I think about myself. Generally whilst looking at myself in that mirror over there. Wait, no, keep going. You were thinking about your career and what? No, I think about my career and I'm thinking and talking about actors that I love and respect whilst doing press junkets for this movie that I've got coming out, Speak No Evil. It looks so good.
然后跟我们讲讲你的感受。好吧，你知道的，我正待在我的“手冲健身房”里，这里是我思考人生的地方。通常是一边看着那边镜子里的自己。等等，不，继续说。你刚才在想你的职业生涯，然后呢？不，我在思考我的职业生涯，我一边在想、一边在谈论那些我热爱和尊敬的演员，同时还要为我即将上映的新片《非礼勿言》做媒体连线采访。这片子看起来太棒了。
I think it's out now. Oh, yeah! Well, hey, huh? It's out now. It's out now. And so many of the actors that I respect and admire, and I wouldn't say emulate because I don't try to emulate anyone. I are actors who have repeatedly kind of done the same thing. And even if they're playing a character
我想现在已经上映了吧。哦，对！好吧，嘿，哈？现在已经上映了。现在已经上映了。我所尊重和钦佩的很多演员——我不会说“效仿”，因为我从不试图效仿任何人——他们都是那些一再重复做同一类事情的演员。哪怕他们扮演的角色
who's a person who's in a different situation or a different scenario, which means the same thing, it's kind of the same guy and. And yet I don't disrespect them for that. And yet I've spent my whole career trying to go like, I'm going to be this guy. No, I'm going to be this guy. No, I'm going to be this guy. And then luckily in Split and then Glass, I got to do many guys all in one, some women as well.
身处不同的情境或不同的剧本中，这意味着本质上是同一个东西，基本上就是同一个人，而且。然而我并没有因此不尊重他们。然而我整个职业生涯都在试图去表现：我要演这个人。不，我要演那个人。不，我要演这个人。然后幸运的是，在《分裂》和后来的《玻璃先生》中，我得以一个人分饰许多人，甚至还有几个女性角色。
So it kind of makes me call any question like the fucking point of playing all these different characters when all the actors I really love are like a type. Yeah, it's a really really good point because I am also a big fan of actors that I mean I really respect character actors that like yourself or like a Daniel Day-Lewis or something that can really morph into somebody completely different with the limp and the thing and the whole. But I really respect an actor that can be comfortable with just disappearing and not doing anything
所以这让我开始质疑：扮演所有这些不同角色的意义到底他妈的在哪儿？既然我真正热爱的所有演员都有固定的银幕形象。对，这真的是一个非常非常好的观点，因为我也是这类演员的超级粉丝——我是说，我真的很尊重那些像你一样、或是像丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯那样能够真正彻底变身成另一个人、带着跛脚和各种细节特征的性格演员。但我同样非常尊重那种能够安于隐形、什么都不做
except just, excuse the term, story, servicing the story and just not doing any sort of performance. Do you know what I mean? Like that takes a lot of talent too. And I love those actors. Do you know what it is? Listen, takes a lot of talent too. And I love those actors. Do you know what it is? Listen, I can put it down to a turning point in my career. Let's go guys.
除了——请原谅这个词——讲故事、服务于故事，而不去做任何浮夸表演的演员。你知道我的意思吗？这其实也很需要天赋。我也很热爱这样的演员。你知道这是为什么吗？听着，这需要很多天赋。我也很热爱这样的演员。你知道这是为什么吗？听着，我可以把它归结为我职业生涯的一个转折点。我们上吧，伙计们。
Yeah. Those... The interview starts now. No. Guys, it's about to get fucking profound. Let's go. I've definitely got an erection. We're not really talking
对。访谈现在才正式开始。不。伙计们，接下来要开始谈点他妈的有深度的内容了。上吧。我绝对已经起生理反应了。我们其实还没开始聊，
until you say the words my in career next to each other. You know what I mean? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I did a film when I was in my mid to late 20s that was, I can't really say what film it is because I'm going to, I'll end up slagging off
直到你把“在”和“职业生涯”这两个词连在一起说。你知道我的意思吗？对。对。对。我二十多岁中后期的时候拍过一部电影，那是——我其实不能说是哪部电影，因为我最终会
at the person that I'm talking about. But slagging off means bad mouthing. Yeah. And, translated for you, colonials. And so, it was great success and everything went great and we got award nominated and we made loads of money and all that. Like a year and a half, two years later,
把我说的那个人贬得一文不值。但“贬损”就是说坏话。对，给你翻译一下，殖民地老乡。所以，那部电影取得了巨大的成功，一切都很顺利，我们获得了奖项提名，赚了好多钱，诸如此类。大约一年半、两年后，
he comes back to me and he's like, dude, I want you to do this film with me. It's based on a book and I read the book and I'm like, I love this character. It's amazing, I get the script, I read the script and they've chopped the balls off the character completely. And this incredibly dynamic, fucking diverse, like acting character that is in the book
他找到我，对我说：“老兄，我想让你跟我一起拍这部电影。它是根据一本书改编的。”我读了那本书，心想：我太喜欢这个角色了，太棒了。我拿到了剧本，读了剧本，结果他们把这个角色的灵魂和锐气给彻底阉割了。原著中那个极其充满活力、他妈的多元化的、极具表演张力的角色，
is just this guy who's like, hello, how are you? Doe-eyed and cries a lot and like, does a lot of silent acting. Does a lot of movie acting, do you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah. Which I'd done previously with this director to create, again, to create a claim and all that stuff.
在剧本里居然变成了一个只会说“你好，你好吗”、眼神清澈无辜、动不动就哭鼻子、还夹杂大量无声表演的家伙。做了大量电影式的表演，你知道我的意思吗？对，对。我以前和这个导演合作时也这么干过，为了再次博取赞誉和那些名利。
It was good for me. And we had a chat about it and I said, well look, I don't think we've really captured who he is in the book and stuff. And we kind of fell out, we kind of had a bit of a tit at it. And he goes, oh no, I get it, you want to do acting. Oh boy. And I was like, that kind of made my decision for me.
这对我有好处。我们为此聊过一次，我说：“听着，我觉得我们并没有真正在片中展现出他在书中的那种特质。”我们有点闹僵了，因为这事儿闹得有点不愉快。然后他说：“哦不，我懂，你是想飙演技。”哦天呐。当时我就想：这句话简直帮我做出了决定。
Because I didn't see this, but inside I was like, do you know what, mate? Yes, I fucking do. Right, it's what I do. But then I have this moment at 45 going like, why are all the actors I really admire not doing any acting? And I'm out here going like, look at my lip, look at my lip, look at my accent.
因为我表面上没说什么，但内心深处在想：你知道吗，老兄？对，我他妈的就是要飙演技。没错，这就是我的工作。但随后我在45岁时有了这样一种时刻：为什么我真正钦佩的所有演员都不去飙演技？而我却在这里大喊：看我的嘴唇，看我的嘴唇，听我的口音。
And, but I like telling the story on purpose. I get pissed off doing movie acting. I don't enjoy it, and yet I do get to watch other actors do movie acting, and I go, fuck, that's brilliant, it's like magic. Yeah, but I mean, as long as it's, not to oversimplify it, but as long as it's real and it comes from a real place, who cares about any of it?
而且，我其实是故意这么讲这个故事的。我对那种“电影式表演”感到厌烦。我并不享受它，然而我却能看着其他演员进行电影式表演，然后心想：操，这太绝了，简直就像魔法一样。对，但我的意思是，只要它是——不是故意把它简单化，但只要它是真实的、源自真实的内心，谁会在乎那些有的没的呢？
It's like, you know. Yeah, and James, when you say movie acting, you're talking about smaller, sort of leading man stuff, right, where you're just sort of like. I'm talking about like. Right. Holy shit. Facting, face acting.
就像，你知道的。对，而且詹姆斯，当你提到“电影式表演”时，你指的是那种较小的、某种程度上偏向主角类型的戏份，对吧？就是那种你只需要——我指的是那种——对。卧槽。面瘫演技，面部微表情表演。
Yeah, this is. Sometimes it's great. Like sometimes I can watch something and go, that's full, that is real. And I'm like, I'm there for it. But nothing acting sometimes, it winds me up so much. I'm with you on that. And I want to watch somebody give something.
对，就是这个。有时它真的很棒。有时我看某些作品会觉得：太绝了，那是真实的情感。然后我就觉得：我完全买账。但有时候那种“什么都不做”的表演真的让我抓狂。在这点上我和你感同身受。我想看演员真正付出点什么。
Like I personally believe that the origins of performance and the origins of performance art, the orange, the orange of performance art is an orchard in Sicily. I think the origin of performance art comes from fucking human sacrifice. It comes from sacrificing a goat or sacrificing a baby or sacrificing a person and a bunch of people watching it going please let it rain this year and that's the origin of theatre. And the person that's up there getting sacrificed, turned into performers, sweating blood, sacrificing something of themselves,
就我个人而言，我认为表演的起源以及行为艺术的起源——“源，源”表演艺术的起源其实是西西里岛的一个果园。我认为行为艺术的起源来自他妈的人类献祭。它源于献祭一只山羊、献祭一个婴儿、或者献祭一个人，然后一群人在旁边看着祈祷：“求求今年下点雨吧。”这就是戏剧的起源。而那个站在上面被献祭的人，最终演变成了表演者，他们挥汗如雨、血洒当场，牺牲了他们身上的某些东西，
whether that's literally their health, their blood, their dignity, their sexuality, their fucking humanity, whatever it is that you're sacrificing when you're on stage or on screen, you've got to leave something up there. You've got to work. I want to see somebody sweat blood. That's not for everybody.
无论是字面意义上的健康、鲜血、尊严、性取向、还是他妈的人性，无论你在舞台上或银幕上牺牲的是什么，你都必须在上面留下点东西。你必须付出努力。我想看到有人挥洒血汗。这并不是适合所有人的。
Some people want to watch an actor just go like that. Right. James, what kind of mushrooms are you on? Because... I... And we will be right back. And now back to the show. No, no, no, I think there's a lot of truth to what you said.
有些人只想看演员就这么随便摆个造型。没错。詹姆斯，你这是磕了什么蘑菇？因为……我……我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。不，不，不，我觉得你刚才说的话很有道理。
And you know, it's funny when you were describing that experience working on that film and you said, yeah, it did well, we got all the awards and then we made lots of money. And I was thinking about, I don't mean to get too heady about this, but as you said, it struck to me, it's like, isn't it funny doing this thing that you do
你知道的，很有意思的是，当你描述那段拍摄某部电影的经历时，你说：“对，它表现得很好，我们赢得了所有奖项，然后赚了大把的钱。”我在想——我并不是想把这个话题搞得太深奥，但正如你所说的那样，它触动了我：做你正在做的这件事难道不觉得很有趣吗？
that one of the marks of success is, if you go to go and do it to create art, if you will, is how much fucking money it made. And at the end of, and maybe I'm getting old right in this moment. It just occurred to me for some reason, it really hit me like, imagine that that's a fucking measure of how good something is,
衡量成功的标准之一——如果你去做这件事是为了创作艺术的话——竟然是它他妈的赚了多少钱。而且到头来——也许我此刻真的是老了。不知为何，这个念头突然涌上心头，深深地触动了我：想象一下，衡量某样东西有多优秀的终极标准，
is how much fucking money it made. And that all these people and all of us, me included, consider what we do to be successful depending upon whether or not it made any fucking money. I'm not even railing against the system. I'm just saying that isn't it funny? Like sometimes it hits you in different times. You think like, wow, isn't that fucking...
竟然是它他妈的赚了多少钱。而所有这些人以及我们所有人，包括我在内，都根据一件事情是否赚了钱来判断我们的工作算不算成功。我甚至不是在抨击这个系统。我只是在说，这难道不是很搞笑吗？有时候这种感悟会在不同的时期击中你。你会想：哇，这他妈难道不——
Here's my spin on it, because... Which is, maybe it sounds like I'm trying to backtrack and justify and reverse engineer something that makes me sound like I've got more integrity. But... But... I think that I do what I do, and I put myself out there for criticism. And even if it's a successful piece, like, not everybody likes it.
我对此有我自己的看法，因为……这听起来可能有点像我在试图事后诸葛亮地为自己辩护、或者自我合理化，好让我显得更有道德节操。但是……但是……我认为我做我所做的事，并把自己置于聚光灯下接受批判。哪怕这是一部非常成功的作品，也不是所有人都喜欢它。
And you take fucking crazy criticism, even in the stuff that people said was good. And what it means when you make some money is that, fuck, people actually went to see it. And we found an audience and we communicated. And we managed to communicate with people because that's all it is, isn't it? Art is just about communication. Sometimes when we say when we're making art, people go like, oh, they're talking about art. What it means is we're trying to communicate.
哪怕在那些被人们交口称赞的作品中，你也会挨他妈莫名其妙的批评。而作品赚钱的真正含义是：操，人们真的去看了。我们找到了受众，并且实现了沟通。我们成功地与人们建立了交流，因为艺术不就是这么回事吗？艺术的核心就是沟通。有时当我们说我们在创作艺术时，人们会说：“哦，他们在谈论艺术。”其实它的意思是我们在试图沟通。
Art is an attempt to communicate. And if you've made some money, what it really means is you managed to communicate. You managed to find, instead of this nebulous thing where it's like, yeah, I've got means is you manage to communicate. Yeah. You manage to find, instead of this nebulous thing where it's like, yeah, I got this movie on a website at the moment, it's doing great. Yeah. 4.5 people have seen it worldwide and it's fucking, it's out there. And you're like, that's even, you can make a great piece of art, but nobody saw it.
艺术就是一种沟通的尝试。如果你赚了钱，它真正的含义就是你成功地实现了沟通。你成功地找到了——而不是那种虚无缥缈的状态，比如：“对，我目前在网站上有部电影，反响特别好。对，全球有四点五个人看过了，它他妈的已经上线了。”然后你会觉得：哪怕你创作了一件伟大的艺术品，但根本没人看，
So you didn't get to communicate. And that is something that's becoming harder and harder to do in the cinemas. Maybe it's easier to do it in the streamers, but it's also like the streamers are like this, this like kaleidoscope of whirlpools that you're getting pulled into, and each whirlpool has a thousand things in it that the algorithm helps you watch.
那你也就没能实现沟通。而这正是目前在电影院里变得越来越难做到的事。也许在流媒体上更容易做到，但流媒体也像是一个万花筒般的湍流漩涡，把你整个人卷进去，每个漩涡里都有成千上万个靠算法推荐给你的内容。
I don't know, but yeah. I think that's fair. I think that's fair. I think that's really fair. It's a marker of how much you were able, how many people you were able to connect with, I suppose, and that makes sense. How did you get into this game? What was the thing?
我不知道，不过——是的。我觉得这很中肯。我觉得这很在理。我觉得这真的很有道理。这确实是一个衡量你能够与多少人产生共鸣的指标，我想是的，这说得通。你是怎么入行的？契机是什么？
Did you come by it, honestly? Did you have parents in the arts, or was it just on your own? I grew up in a council estate in Glasgow called Drum Chapel. Council estate is something you guys call, not schemes, projects. So I was in high school, it was about 15, 16. We were doing Macbeth in English.
你是根正苗红地入行的吗？你父母是搞艺术的，还是完全靠你自己的？我在格拉斯哥的一个名叫德拉姆查佩尔（Drum Chapel）的市政公屋区长大。市政公屋区就是你们所说的——不是贫民区，而是项目区。我上高中时大概15、16岁。我们在英语课上学《麦克白》。
My English teacher knew a director and an actor who had done Macbeth in the 70s, and he came in and talked to us. I recognized him immediately, because he was like a movie actor. He'd done movies with Chris O'Donnell. And I was like, I've seen you in Vertical Limit. You're like the bad guy in Vertical Limit
我的英语老师认识一个在70年代演过《麦克白》的导演和演员，他来学校给我们做讲座。我一眼就认出他来了，因为他就像个真正的电影明星。他跟克里斯·奥唐纳拍过电影。当时我就想：我在《垂直极限》里见过你。你就是《垂直极限》里那个大反派，
with fucking Chris O'Fucking Donnell. And I was like, wow. And then I was like, I've also seen you in a film with fucking Arnold Schwarzenegger. And he was pretty cool. He took a lot of shit from some of the guys in the class. And at the end of it, I just went up and I said, listen, I'm sorry about that.
跟克里斯·他妈的·奥唐纳搭档的那个。当时我就想：哇塞。然后我又想：我还看过你跟阿诺·施瓦辛格合作的电影。他其实挺酷的。他当时承受了班上一些男生不少的嘲讽和刁难。讲座结束后，我径直走过去对他说：“听着，为刚才那些人的态度向你道歉。
Thank you very much for coming. If you're making a movie again, because he was a film director, would you please consider letting me come and making tea or coffee for you? And for a week or something like that. And he called back months later and he was like, is that kid still there? Send him to the production office.
非常感谢你能来。如果你以后还要拍电影的话——因为他是个电影导演——能不能考虑让我去给你端茶倒水？哪怕就去干一周左右也行。”结果几个月后他竟然打电话来了，问：“那个小孩还在吗？让他来制作办公室一趟。”
He was making this movie about child prostitution and pornography in Glasgow. And he was like, here's the script, read it. And I read it and he went, come in here. Can you try and play Kevin? This young guy called Kevin Savage. And he was like, can you make yourself cry? I'd never done any acting at this point. And I got the part.
他当时正在拍一部关于格拉斯哥儿童卖淫和色情制品的电影。他见面就说：“这是剧本，拿去读。”我读完后他问：“进来。你觉得你能试着演一下凯文吗？这个叫凯文·萨维奇的年轻小伙。”然后他问：“你能让自己哭出来吗？”我当时从来没演过戏。然后我就得到了这个角色。
And by the way, we left the room and he was like, we found the guy, this is him. And do you know what's really weird, right? There was a TV show called Streetwise. Streetwise! It was a kid's show and it was about mountain bike couriers in London that were led by a saxophone playing Andy
顺便说一句，我们离开房间后，他就跟别人说：“我们找到合适的人了，就是他。”你知道最诡异的是什么吗？当时有一部电视剧叫《街头智慧》（Streetwise）！那是一部儿童剧，讲的是伦敦的自行车快递员，由一个吹萨克斯的安迪·瑟金斯领导。
Serkis. No way. Yeah man. I loved it. They were like crime fighting mountain bike couriers and Andy Serkis. It was brilliant and he played the saxophone. And I was like that's Andy Serkis. He was walking into the production office and Andy was playing a Glaswegian pimp with dreadlocks. And my first bit of being a professional actor was literally being told you're going to play the part and then I walked out and Andy Serkis went, are you actually from Glasgow? Are you like the real deal from a council estate or whatever?
不会吧。真的老兄。我太喜欢了。他们是一群打击犯罪的山羊自行车快递员，还有安迪·瑟金斯。太绝了，他在里面吹萨克斯。当时我就想：那不是安迪·瑟金斯吗？他正走进制作办公室，而安迪当时在片中扮演一个留着长 dreadlocks（脏辫）的格拉斯哥皮条客。我职业生涯演戏的处女秀，literally就是有人通知说“你要演这个角色”，然后我走出门，安迪·瑟金斯就走过来问：“你真的是格拉斯哥本地人吗？你是公屋区出来的纯正本地人还是怎么着？”
And I was like, yeah man. He was like, great, come sit with me. And he was like recording me and recording my voice and I was teaching Andy yeah man, he was like, great, come sit with me. And he was like recording me and recording my voice and I was teaching Andy fucking Serkis. From street wise, how to do my ass. For my sister, for my sister, Tracy in Wisconsin, Andy Serkis is Gollum in Lord of the Rings, he was Planet of the Apes, he's a great character actor,
然后我说：“对啊，老兄。”他说：“太好了，过来跟我坐坐。”然后他开始录制我说话的声音，而我当时居然在教安迪·他妈的·瑟金斯。——来自《街头智慧》，教他怎么说我的家乡话。致我在威斯康星州的妹妹特蕾西：安迪·瑟金斯就是《指环王》里的咕噜，他还演过《猩球崛起》，是个伟大的性格演员，
also great director, incredible guy. Just a good guy as well. Who was the director of this film, of the child prostitution that discovered you? It was a movie called The Near Room. It was a reference to Muhammad Ali, talking about the space that he would go, I think, before a fight with the alligators,
也是个伟大的导演，不可思议的家伙。而且人也非常好。发现你的那部关于儿童卖淫的电影的导演是谁？那是一部名叫《近距离》（The Near Room）的电影。这个名字是致敬穆罕默德·阿里，谈论他以前在比赛前会去的地方，我想，在鳄鱼出没的地方，
play trombones. And it was a guy called David Heyman, not to be confused with the producer who does Harry Potter and since then many, many things. But Scottish actor, director, philanthropist, and really good actor. But I'd said to him, and I was not that good in the film, and I've said publicly quite a few times,
吹长号。导演是一个叫大卫·海曼的人，不要跟那个制作了《哈利·波特》以及后来许许多多大制作的制片人大卫·海曼混淆。那位是个苏格兰演员、导演、慈善家，也是个非常优秀的演员。但我曾对他说过——我在那部电影里演得其实不怎么好，我也在公开场合说过好几次了——
I'd love to pay him back, I'd love to be in something for him. And he sent me something one day and I was like, ah, I don't think it's quite right for me. Yeah, yeah, yeah, right, right. There's not enough acting in it. So from that point on, and then as you kind of built this career for yourself over many, many years and you just kind of kept going up
我很想报答他，很想参演他的某部作品。结果有一天他给我发了一份剧本，我看过之后心想：啊，这感觉不太适合我。对，对，对，没错，没错。里面的演戏空间还不够多。所以从那个时候开始，在接下来的好多年里，你为自己一步步打造了这样的演艺事业，然后你一直往上，
and up and up and up and up and more, and bigger projects, projects that have more recognition and audiences are grew and everything. Is there something that you learned that was so valuable that you can share? Because I think, I look back when I was a young actor and I'm like, I wish somebody would have fucking told me blank A, B and C.
不断地往上、往上、往上攀登，参与了更多、更大规模的项目，获得了更多的认可，受众也越来越多。有没有什么是你学到了、觉得极其珍贵而想要分享的？因为我觉得，每当我回看自己年轻时的演员生涯时，我就会想：我要是早点知道A、B和C就好了。
And then you get older and you look back and you wish there's no, nobody pulls you aside and said, this is how the business works, this is what you should be looking for. Like I wish somebody would have told me, you know. Camera at 10 pounds? Or something like that.
然后等你年纪大了回过头看，你会发现其实并没有人会把你拉到一旁对你说：“这才是行业运作的方式，这才是你应该寻找的东西。”就像我希望当初有人能告诉我——十英镑的摄影机？诸如此类的话。
Or just the business side of it too. Must have been driving over a canyon when you got that note. You know what? Sean must be using two cameras right now then. Yeah. Sean must be using two cameras right now then. Oh my god. You guys are harsh. You guys are friends, right? You guys like each other.
或者是关于商业运作方面的内幕。你接到那个通知的时候，车一定正开在悬崖边上吧。你知道吗？肖恩现在肯定用了两个摄像头吧。对。肖恩现在肯定用了两个摄像头。我的天呐。你们俩太刻薄了。你们真的是朋友吧？你们俩挺喜欢彼此的吧？
We're very old friends. Well, but James, so you didn't really kind of start this super passionate about it. Like, this wasn't your plan really to be an actor out of the gate, right? No. Wasn't it? Weren't you going to maybe be a priest at one point or is that just a Wikipedia lie? No way.
我们是非常老的朋友了。不过，詹姆斯，所以你一开始并不是对表演超级有热情对吧？这并不是你最初跨入这个行业时的计划，对吧？不是的。不是吗？你以前不是打算当个神父什么的吗？还是说那只是维基百科上的谣言？怎么可能。
No. You do deep research here. It's a lie that I've told in many interviews. Really? Yeah, just to try and make myself sound like I'm the kind of guy you want to corrupt and attract people to. No, I considered being a very specific kind of priest. Not a handsy one for a start.
没有。你们这里的深度调研做得真好。那是我在很多采访里瞎编的谎言。真的吗？对，就是为了让自己听起来像那种你想去腐蚀、去吸引大家关注的坏小子。没有，我曾经考虑过当一种非常特殊的神父。首先可不是那种手脚不干净的神父。
Then I'm out. We just lost Sean. I thought being a missionary sounded kind of cool because you get to go to far flung places and do far flung things and have a great time. I then started to finally find a little bit of luck with the opposite sex, around about 15 and 16. I went, I am not selling my sexuality to God for the rest of my life.
那我就退出了。我们刚刚失去肖恩了。我当时觉得当传教士听起来挺酷的，因为你可以去到遥远的地方，做一些轰轰烈烈的事，过得很开心。后来大概在15、16岁左右，我终于在异性缘上开始走运了，
So it was Catholicism, wasn't it? So that took me out of that. I was going to join the Navy at one point, and then I was going to go to university, and then I thought, listen, I did this acting thing when I was 16. I'll try it for acting school, the one acting school in my town, in my city,
于是我想：我可绝不会为了上帝把我的性取向出卖一辈子。所以那是天主教，对吧？这就把我从那条路上拉出来了。我一度考虑过加入海军，然后打算去上大学，接着我想：听着，我16岁时尝试过演戏，我不妨去考个戏剧学校——我们镇上、我们城市里唯一的那所戏剧学校，
and I luckily got in. And the rest. And is this the Royal Scottish Academy of Music and Drama? Formerly known as, now known as the Royal Conservatoire of Scotland. And this is, you don't just pay 10 bucks and get in to that place. This is a very, very prestigious place.
而且我很幸运地考上了。剩下的就是——而这就是皇家苏格兰音乐戏剧学院？以前叫这个名字，现在叫苏格兰皇家音乐学院。而且那个地方可不是随随便便交10块钱就能进去的。那是一个非常非常声誉卓著的地方。
I come from a country with a proud history of socialist democracy, so luckily I was the last, I think I was the last year to have their tuition completely paid for them. So I didn't get in. But still, it ain't some swinging door there. This is a high-end institution. Yeah, yeah.
我来自一个拥有引以为傲的社会主义民主历史的国家，所以很幸运，我想我是最后一届学费全免的人。所以我没进去。不过话说回来，那里可不是什么随随便便就能进的旋转门。这是一个高端机构。对，没错。
It was kind of, I guess it was tough to get in. I was really, I was lucky I got in at my first try. If I hadn't got in at my first try, I might have gone off and done one of those other things, you know? But listen, to answer your question, Sean, I would say there's a couple of things I would pass on. One is try and be more American
我猜想，进去还是挺难的。我很幸运，第一次尝试就考上了。如果我第一次没考上，我可能就去干别的了，你知道吗？不过听着，为了回答你的问题，肖恩，我想我有几点经验可以分享。首先是尽量表现得更像美国人
in terms of what you do as an actor. Try and create your own work. Because you guys, I think it's changing now, but me coming up, it felt like us as young actors, it was like you're a hired gun. You're like a carpenter that's hired in. And you guys, when I met you guys, you guys, when I met you guys back in like 2003
就你作为演员的所作所为而言。尝试创作你自己的作品。因为你们——我觉得现在情况在变，但在我刚出道的时候，我们年轻演员感觉就像是拿钱办事的雇佣兵。就像是被雇来的木匠。而你们，当我遇到你们的时候，你们，当我遇到你们是在2003年左右
when I first started coming to America, I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, you're like, you've got two editions a month and you've got a production company and you've written four scripts and you're like, how'd you do this? Like, what do you mean? You got a development deal with who?
当我刚开始来美国的时候，我想，哇，哇，哇，等等，你们就像是，一个月有两期杂志，还有自己的制作公司，写了四个剧本，你们就想，你是怎么做到的？什么意思？你跟谁签了开发协议？
I was like, what? I could not believe, but it's also grown up within an industry that is actually an industry, whereas in Britain, it's a little bit, we feel lucky to be here and we feel lucky to get to do the secret thing that ferries and elves get to do, and it feels a bit more like a cottage industry. Yeah, I guess that's kind of what I meant a little bit,
我当时想，什么？我简直不敢相信，但这也是在一个真正成型的行业中成长起来的，而在英国，情况有点，我们能来到这里就觉得自己很幸运，能去做那些只有仙女和精灵才能做的秘密工作也觉得很幸运，感觉更像是一个家庭手工业。对，我想这大概就是我刚才的意思，
was like, do you do, like, you know, being an actor is plenty, you know, there's a lot of work that goes with that. But as to your point, a lot of people are realizing the industry's changing, you kind of have to be all things in order to, you have to kind of cultivate your own work for yourself. And so I just didn't know if that was something
就像是，你知道吗，当好一个演员就已经很不容易了，这里面有很多工作要做。但正如你所说，很多人意识到行业正在改变，为了生存，你必须成为全能的人，你必须为自己开辟出自己的作品。所以我只是不知道这是不是你现在正在做的事，
that you're doing now, like are you delving into other aspects, directing, producing, writing, anything like that? I'm directing at the moment, I'm about to go into prep for my first film in the 26th of August. It's really exciting. Which is really exciting. But I don't want to produce, I don't want to write, I don't want to do those things.
比如你有没有涉足其他领域，导演、制片、编剧之类的？我现在在当导演，8月26日我就要为我的第一部电影开始做筹备了。这真的很让人兴奋。这真的非常令人兴奋。但我不想当制片人，我不想写剧本，我不想做那些事情。
I've done those things in the past and I did not find it to be my wheelhouse. What's drawing you to the directing? Control, power, abuse of it. Um... Um... Um... Not the paycheck.
我过去做过那些事，但发现那不是我的强项。是什么吸引你去当导演？控制欲、权力、对权力的滥用。嗯……嗯……嗯……不是为了片酬。
Not the paycheck. Do you know what? I've been looking to tell stories about my own country for a long, long time and every single story I got sent was like gritty Scottish drama. Yeah, yeah. About drugs and the kind of neighborhoods I grew up in I've been traveling around my own country about people who have no opportunities. But likewise, this is a true story. But I just burped on camera.
不是为了片酬。你知道吗？我寻找讲述自己国家故事的机会已经很久很久了，我收到的每一个故事剧本都像是那种残酷的苏格兰正剧。对，对。关于毒品以及我长大的那种街区，我一直在我的国家到处走访那些毫无机会的人。但同样，这是一个真实的故事。不过我刚才在镜头前打了个嗝。
Do not cut that. I can smell it. It's only audio. It's only audio. Thank you. Audio smells. Do you want me to tell you what it's about? Do you guys care?
别把那个剪掉。我能闻到。只有音频。只有音频。谢谢。音频有味道。你想让我告诉你它是讲什么的吗？你们在乎吗？
Yeah, please. Of course we do. It's not going to be out for like 14 years. Don't worry. Are you in it or are you just going to direct it? I need to be in it. I need to be in it to get it bounded. It's a true story about two rappers from Dundee who rapped about Scottish things in
好，请讲。我们当然在乎。大概14年内都不会上映。别担心。你在里面演还是只负责导演？我得演。我必须参演才能把项目拉动起来。这是一个真实的故事，讲的是邓迪的两个说唱歌手，他们用
their Scottish accent. They came down to London in the early 2000s and they did an audition for Sony. They literally got laughed out of the room, even though they were awesome. And they came back like a year later. They'd re-recorded all their demos and all their backing tracks with American accents and they pretended to be these two skater dudes from Hemet in California.
苏格兰口音说唱苏格兰的事。他们在2000年代初来到伦敦，去索尼面试。尽管他们棒极了，但他们字面意思上是被轰出了房间，笑出了声。大约一年后他们回来了。他们用美国口音重新录制了所有的样曲和伴奏，并假装自己是来自加利福尼亚海梅特的两个滑板小子。
And they got a record deal from the same label that day for 35 grand. And they got housed and they got given a studio and they got an A&R rep and for two and a half years They pretended to be 24 7 like even when they were alone together They pretended to be these two dudes called no brains. Wow and And they nearly made it. They made it. It's an incredible story But yes, that's that's our that's that's a film. We're making that
同一天，他们从同一家唱片公司拿到了一份3.5万美元的唱片合约。他们得到了住处，得到了一个录音室，有了一个艺人与曲目（A&R）代表，在两年半的时间里，他们全天候地假装——甚至当他们俩单独在一起时，他们也假装自己是两个叫“没头脑”的家伙。哇，而且他们差点就成功了。他们成功了。这是一个不可思议的故事，但是的，这就是我们的，这就是一部电影，我们在拍这个
It's called it's called California Scheming. Oh, that's so good. Wait, who's doing it with you? It's just me on my own with my camcorder. Yep, and a mirror. I'm going to shoot out my iPhone in my basement. I'm really excited. We're independent at the moment.
它叫——它叫《加州骗局》。哦，太棒了。等等，谁跟你一起拍？只有我一个人拿着摄像机。没错，还有一面镜子。我打算在地下室用我的iPhone拍。我真的很兴奋。我们目前是独立的。
Studio Canal are involved, Screen Scotland are involved. No, but I mean, it's two guys. It's you're one of the guys and who's your partner? I ain't one of the guys. I'm too old. These guys were like 1920. Well, Will, you can hang on. I don't know where Will's going with this.
Studio Canal（映欧嘉纳）参与了，苏格兰银幕（Screen Scotland）也参与了。不，我的意思是，这是两个人的故事。你是其中一个人，你的搭档是谁？我不是其中一个人。我太老了。这些人大概19、20岁。好吧，威尔，你可以坚持。我不知道威尔想说啥。
Will, you got a pretty high, low range there. You can play in 1920. I'm just saying. Can you give us just a little bit of rapping, Will? Yeah, and Scotland and Scottish. And the Scottish. No, no, no, they're American. Yeah, they're American, so you're perfect.
威尔，你那里的音域高低跨度挺大的。你可以演19、20岁的人。我只是说说。威尔，你能给我们来一小段说唱吗？对，还有苏格兰语。还有苏格兰语。不，不，不，他们是美国人。对，他们是美国人，所以你太合适了。
Oh, Sean, listen to James' story much? Fucking Jesus. I was throwing a swift in there. Take this as an opportunity to audition just a little bit, so. Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do. I'm the beatbox guy. No, I'm the beatbox.
哦，肖恩，你平时听詹姆斯的歌听得多吗？他妈的耶稣。我刚才顺便插了一句。把这当成一个试镜的机会，稍微表现一下吧。嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟。我是说唱盒（beatbox）达人。不，我是说唱盒。
You do the rapping. No, you're rapping. You're auditioning for this. Okay. All right, nevermind. Now, James, what about, now this film that you're gonna be. I was rapping, go ahead. This film that you're gonna be directing,
你来唱。不，你来唱。你在为这个试镜呢。好吧。好吧，没关系。那么，詹姆斯，关于——现在你将要执导的这部电影，我刚才在说唱呢，继续。你将要执导的这部电影，
the role that you're gonna be playing in it, is it a role that is appropriate for you to do sort of character type acting, or is it a role that would be more appropriate, if you were to do that level of acting, would you be overplaying the part, or do you just need to just be a guy? Or can we see some good hard looks?
你在里面要演的角色，是一个适合你进行那种性格类型表演的角色，还是一个这样的角色：如果你要达到那种表演水平，你是不是会把角色演过头，还是说你只需要做回普通人就行了？或者我们能看到一些精彩冷酷的眼神？
Will you just throw a bunch of hard looks? I think there's going to be some hard looks. There's going to be some... Yeah, smoking a look. Hard looks. I think it just requires me to be kind of me, but I might get nervous at the last minute throwing a limp.
你会不会直接来一堆冷酷的眼神？我觉得会有一些冷酷的眼神。会有一些……对，充满杀气的眼神。冷酷的眼神。我想这只需要我做回我自己，不过我可能会在最后一分钟紧张得加上一瘸一拐的毛病。
Or just have the guy have a cold the whole movie. Yeah, that's a good idea. He's got to be Scottish. Can I make this, first of all, the hard looks are good, so I don't want to eat into them, because you do them really, really well. Have you thought about an eye patch? Hey, listen, if I internalize the eye patch, you will see the eye patch.
或者让这个家伙在整部电影里都感冒。对，这主意不错。他必须是苏格兰人。首先，我能说吗，冷酷的眼神很好，所以我不想破坏它们，因为你演得真的、真的很好。你考虑过戴眼罩吗？嘿，听着，如果我把眼罩内化了，你就能看到眼罩。
Wow. I want to talk about, wait, first of all, I know probably everybody comes up to you and says how brilliant you were in Split, but I just thought it was, I thought it was like you should have won an Academy Award. Like it was an incredible performance. And tell me, you played all these different characters
哇。我想谈谈，等等，首先，我知道可能每个人走到你面前都说你在《分裂》里演得多么出色，但我就是觉得，我觉得你本该赢得奥斯卡奖。这简直是一场不可思议的表演。告诉我，你演了所有这些不同的角色，
because the guy was a fucking serial killer. Split personality. Yeah, but also these different accents and different characters and you buy each and every one of them, like to your point, they were all real, they were all very real. So tell me about the process and were you scared to do that many different kind of people?
因为这家伙是个他妈的连环杀手。人格分裂。对，但还有这些不同的口音和不同的角色，你对每一个都信服了，就像你说的，它们都是真实的，都非常真实。所以跟我讲讲这个过程，你害怕扮演这么多种不同的人吗？
I was not scared. I got that job pretty last minute because It was many be whacking Phoenix. Oh, right. Excuse me. I just burped again. I'm drinking fizzy water guys. Yeah It's all I drink. It's all I drink Whacking Phoenix was supposed to do it and because he had a relationship with M. Night Shyamalan from like Signs, and was he in the village as well? He's thinking he's in the village, isn't he? Yeah, looks like. And then, I don't know what happened,
我当时并不害怕。我接到那份工作挺突然的，因为原本是杰昆·菲尼克斯演的。哦，对。不好意思。我又打嗝了。我喝的是气泡水，各位。对，我只喝这个。我只喝这个。原本应该是杰昆·菲尼克斯来演的，因为他和M·奈特·沙马兰从《灵异象限》开始就有合作，他是不是还演了《神秘村》？他是在《神秘村》里吧？对，好像是。然后，我不知道发生了什么，
but like two weeks before they started shooting, he read the script or something, I don't want to do this, and for whatever reason he fell out, and so I get the call saying, hey, do you want to read this? It's super secret. You got to read it and then like give it back.
但在开拍前大约两周，他读了剧本还是怎么的，就说“我不想演这个”，不管出于什么原因他退出了，所以我接到了电话，说：“嘿，你想读读这个吗？这绝对保密。你得读完然后把它还回去。”
And I was like, cool. And they were saying it's M. Night Shyamalan. I've been a fan of loads of his films. And I was like, definitely. It came to me and I thought, this has got the potential to be really good. Like it could also go off a cliff and be really bad. But I think that's the case with most really interesting
当时我想，酷。他们说这是M·奈特·沙马兰的电影。我一直是他的很多电影的粉丝。所以我想，绝对的。剧本到了我手里，我想，这有潜力变得非常好。当然，它也可能直接跌落悬崖变得一塌糊涂。但我想大多数真正有趣或好玩的事情都是这样。
or fun things. They could go either way. That's not a criticism of his material there, by the way. But yeah, it was a lot of characters. It was a lot of work, but it was well written and I thought, it's good hard work. And as long as I've got enough time to come up with this, we can figure it out. But it was down to the wire, trying to find all the characterizations. The last one we found was at the table read. And fuck, like Jason Blum had flown in, and like people from Universal had flown into Philly where we made the film, and I'm doing this table read,
它们可能走向任何一个极端。顺便说一句，这不是对他的剧本的批评。不过是的，角色很多。工作量很大，但剧本写得很好，我想，这是扎实的好活。只要我有足够的时间来琢磨这些，我们就能搞定。但当时已经是千钧一发，试图找出所有的角色特征。我们找到的最后一个角色是在剧本围读会上。他妈的，杰森·布鲁姆（Jason Blum）都飞过来了，环球影业的人也飞到了我们拍电影的费城，我正在进行剧本围读，
going like, we haven't really found the character Hedwig, and at the last minute. Who modeled it after Blum? Yeah, I just drove around LA and a van all the time. I just want to say to Blum, you finally made it onto the podcast. You know what I mean? Yeah, yeah.
心想，我们还没真正找到海德薇格（Hedwig）这个角色，直到最后一分钟。是按布鲁姆为原型塑造的吗？对，我只是整天开着一辆面包车在洛杉矶到处转。我只想对布鲁姆说，你终于上播客了。你知道我的意思吗？对，对。
He's listening, he's listening. He's in the queue, he's coming in. Oh, we love him. Very much like he's gonna be here soon. We're gonna bring him on. We are gonna bring him on. He's cool, I think their company do good things. For Tracy, Jason Blum is Blumhouse.
他在听，他在听。他在排队，他马上要进来了。哦，我们爱死他了。就像他很快就会来一样。我们要把他请来。我们一定要把他请来。他很酷，我觉得他们的公司做得很棒。对翠西来说，杰森·布鲁姆就是布鲁姆屋（Blumhouse）。
The Blumhouse Pictures. And he does also, he also does drive around LA in a van. So Jason's right about that. He does. Yeah, a plumbing van. But this new film is a Blumhouse as well, right? Speak No Evil. This new film is a Blumhouse as well.
布鲁姆屋影业。而且他也确实，他平时也确实开着一辆面包车在洛杉矶转悠。所以杰森这点没说错。他确实开。对，一辆水管工的面包车。但这部新电影也是布鲁姆屋的，对吧？《非礼勿言》。这部新电影也是布鲁姆屋的。
And it does, the Blumhouse does so well. The trailer looks great. I think so too. We love him, we are going to have him on. But wait, I want to hear, so you're there, you haven't found the last thing, you're at the table reading, it's like fucking down to the wire.
而且布鲁姆屋做得太成功了。预告片看起来棒极了。我也这么觉得。我们爱他，我们要把他请来。但等等，我想听听，所以你在现场，还没找到最后那个角色的感觉，你在做剧本围读，简直他妈的千钧一发。
It's down to the wire, and the director, Knight, goes, listen, I think for the character of Hedwig, the kid in the movie, he's like, I think you should do it with like a sibilant S. I'm like, like a lisp? He's like, we say sibilant S. And I was like, all right, cool, I'll do it with a sibilant lisp.
千钧一发之际，导演奈特说：“听着，我觉得对于海德薇格这个角色，电影里的那个小孩，我觉得你应该用带有咝音的S来演。”我说：“像大舌音一样？”他说：“我们说的是带咝音的S。”我说：“好吧，酷，我会用带咝音的大舌音来演。”
And I'm like, we say Sibilant Ass, and I was like, all right, cool, I'll do it with a sibilant lisp. And I'm like, what, I'm just gonna throw this in to the table read? I was like, are you kidding? Oh, fuck, okay. And then within seconds of doing it, I was like, this was a good call. And suddenly the whole character came together. But no, look, it was a lot of heavy lifting that job,
我说：“我们说的是带咝音的S，我说：‘好吧，酷，我会用带咝音的大舌音来演。’”然后我想，什么，我这就把这直接扔进剧本围读里？我当时想，你在开玩笑吗？哦，操，好吧。结果仅仅几秒钟之后，我就觉得，这招太妙了。突然之间，整个角色就成型了。不过说真的，那份工作确实很费力，
but if you can lift it, then it's a good lift. Do you know what I mean? I'm speaking like I'm a total bro. But again, for Tracy, when you shoot a movie, it's all out of order. You're not taking care of, you do one character and then you're done, and then in James' case, you do another character and then you're done and then in James' case you do another character and then you're done.
但如果你能扛得动，那就是一次很好的锻炼。你知道我的意思吗？我说话听起来完全像个肌肉猛男。不过话说回来，对翠西来说，你拍电影的时候，场景都是打乱拍的。你不用按顺序来，你演完一个角色就完成了，然后在詹姆斯的例子里，你演完另一个角色就完成了，然后在詹姆斯的例子里你演完另一个角色就完成了。
So you're probably playing what, sometimes three or four different characters on the same day, right? And would you agree that you seem to be the kind of real actor that will find the version of each character inside you? And if that is true, then when you're playing in a movie where you're playing multiple characters
所以你可能在同一天里扮演着三个甚至四个不同的角色，对吧？你是否同意，你似乎是那种真正的演员，会在自己内心深处找到每个角色的版本？如果这是真的，那么当你在一部电影中扮演多个角色，
and basically going through schizophrenia, does it ever become super taxing on yourself to explore all those different parts of yourselves and try to be as authentic and as believable as possible and it sort of like triggers and brings these characters up in you and you don't know who the hell you are then when you go home?
并且基本上经历着精神分裂时，去探索自己内心所有这些不同的部分，并试图表现得尽可能真实可信，这会不会对你自己造成极大的精神负担？这是否会像触发器一样在你体内唤醒这些角色，以至于你回家时甚至不知道自己到底是谁？
Or you're just doing a lisp. I'm just fucking. I'm just fucking. You see me, man. You see me. I think there's only really been one time in my career where I brought it home. Actually, there's maybe three times in my career where I brought it home. Actually, there's maybe three times in my career
或者你只是在学大舌音。我他妈开玩笑呢。我他妈开玩笑呢。你懂我，老兄。你懂我。我觉得在我职业生涯中，真正把角色情绪带回家只有一次。其实，在我职业生涯中大概有三次把角色情绪带回家了。其实，在我职业生涯中大概有三次
where I brought it home. But I do like what you just said, it is always me. It doesn't matter how weird it is or how wacky it looks or how different it seems from my personality, it's always me. There's no becoming the character, it's always me. There's always, it's some version of yourself. You know what I mean?
把角色情绪带回家了。但我确实喜欢你刚才说的话，那里面永远都是我。不管它有多怪异，不管它看起来多么疯狂，或者跟我的性格看起来有多大区别，里面永远都是我。没有什么变成角色这回事，永远都是我。永远都是你自己的某种版本。你知道我的意思吗？
That's all you have to give. And if some other actor says that, but no, I actually do transform into someone else, like I'm cool with that, I'll believe them too. But for me, it's just, all you have is your own tool, your own body. But the only jobs that I brought at home were Macbeth, because it was all about losing children for me,
这就是你全部能拿得出手的东西。如果有别的演员说，不，我确实能转化成另一个人，好吧，我对此没意见，我也相信他们。但对我来说，你所有的只有你自己的工具，你自己的身体。不过我唯一把情绪带回家的工作是《麦克白》，因为对我来说那部戏全关于失去孩子，
and that, just the whole of Macbeth, I was apparently not an easy person to live with when I did Macbeth. And then whenever I've played a victim, I've played a victim kind of twice now, maybe in a Danny Boyle movie called Trans and then a movie that I just made in Germany. And I just felt awful about myself
而且，仅仅是整部《麦克白》下来，显然我在演《麦克白》时并不是一个好相处的人。然后就是每当我扮演受害者时——我到现在大概演过两次受害者，一次是在丹尼·博伊尔的电影《幻影冲刺》（Trance）里，另一次是我刚刚在德国拍的一部电影。我当时对自己的感觉糟糕透顶，
because I was such a victim of circumstance in other people's control. I did not enjoy that experience and that's the only times that I've ever brought it home with me, those three. Wow. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Now in this trailer for Speak No Evil, you, by the way, you look huge.
因为我在别人的控制下成了环境的绝对受害者。我一点也不喜欢那种经历，那是我唯一三次把角色情绪带回家的时候。哇。我们马上回来。好的，欢迎回到节目中。现在在《非礼勿言》的预告片里，你，顺便说一句，你看上去块头好大。
Like you were, like, did you go to the gym? Like just for this part? Cool it, Sean. I'm just asking. I'm like six foot four. It's on my IMDB page. I'm like bigger than Hugh Jackman. Wait, talk about it.
就像是，你去了健身房吗？专门为了这个角色？冷静点，肖恩。我只是问问。我身高六尺四（约1.93米）。我的IMDb页面上写着呢。我比休·杰克曼还壮。等等，聊聊这个。
Are you really six foot four? No, Sean. I'm five seven. Oh, how are you? By the way, Sean, you said it. I just want to say it should be noted, because to be fair, you said that you often bring it home from a movie. Sure.
你真的身高六尺四吗？没有，肖恩。我只有五尺七（约1.70米）。哦，你好啊？顺便说一句，肖恩，这话是你说的。我只想说这应该记下来，因为公平地说，你曾说过你经常把电影里的东西带回家。当然。
Sorry, by it I mean craft service. You usually bring a lot of it home with you, don't you? Just bags, yeah. I just came home back from a family reunion, there's all this extra food there, and it's just like, there's like a bag of donuts, I grab those, I from a family reunion. There's all this extra food there. And it's just like, there's like a bag of donuts. I grabbed those, grabbed a couple other things.
抱歉，我说的“东西”指的是剧组的餐饮服务（craft service）。你通常会把很多那种东西带回家，对吧？就几袋子，对。我刚从一个家庭聚会回来，那里面有所有这些多余的食物，就像这样，有一大袋甜甜圈，我顺手拿了，我从家庭聚会回来。那里有所有这些多余的食物。就像这样，有一袋甜甜圈。我顺手拿了，又顺便拿了其他几样东西。
Did you really? Yeah, but there's all this extra food and I felt so bad throwing it out. Anyway. What's that image of you, Sean Hayes, bringing a bag of donuts onto a plane? Hugging everybody goodbye with you slinging the bag over their back while you hug them all.
你真的拿了？对，但是有那么多多余的食物，扔了让我觉得太可惜了。总之。那是个什么画面啊，肖恩·海斯提着一袋甜甜圈上飞机？拥抱每一个人告别，把袋子甩在他们背上，同时拥抱他们。
Hollywood bad boy steals donuts from family reunions. Yeah, powdered sugar just on people. Hollywood bad boy. Hollywood bad boy, Sean Hays. No wait, you do look so buff in that trailer. It's like crazy. You look like you worked out crazy. Do you know what, I didn't do it for the movie.
好莱坞坏小子从家庭聚会上偷甜甜圈。对，身上还沾满了糖粉。好莱坞坏小子。好莱坞坏小子，肖恩·海斯。等一下，你在那部预告片里看起来确实很健美。简直太疯狂了。你看起来像是疯狂健身过。你知道吗，我不是为了拍电影才这么练的。
I just did it for the fun. I did it because we were in the lockdown, we were in pandemic line. I just had my second the fun. I did it because we were in the lockdown, we were in pandemic land. I just had my second child and I was like, you know what, I can't let having a child, again, stop me from exercising for three years. So I was like, I'm going to double down. And I started eating crazy amounts of food
我只是为了好玩才练的。我这么做是因为我们在封城期间，我们在疫情大流行时期。我刚迎来了我的第二为了好玩。我这么做是因为我们在封城期间，我们在疫情大流行时期。我刚迎来了我的第二个孩子，当时我想，你知道吗，我不能再让有孩子这件事阻止我锻炼三年了。所以我当时想，我要加倍努力。我开始吃疯狂分量的食物，
and lifting crazy heavy weight. And two years later, this script came along and it was like, oh, perfect, this works. Yeah, yeah. Let's talk about when you decide to toggle between mediums, when you go between theater and film. Because you've done an incredible amount of very prestigious theater work,
并举起疯狂重量的杠铃。两年后，这个剧本出现了，当时我想，哦，太完美了，这下用得上了。对，对。我们来聊聊当你决定在不同媒介之间切换时的情况，当你游走于戏剧和电影之间时。因为你做过数量惊人的、非常高端的戏剧工作，
and I would imagine that's very, very rewarding to you. But you also have to pay the bills, and you're a big movie star, and you probably enjoy doing that stuff too. So how do you decide between, is there a rhythm you like to maintain, or is it just kind of job to job kind of thing? Rhythm is a dancer.
我想象这一定对你非常有意义、非常充实。但你也得付账单，而且你是个大电影明星，你可能也很喜欢拍电影。那你如何在两者之间做决定呢？你有什么喜欢维持的节奏，还是说只是一种见步行步的类型？节奏是个舞者。
It's a speak in my language. Honestly, wonderful. Wait, wait, let's try to get some music in right here. Wonderful, that, wonderful. Wait, wait, let's try to get some music in right here. Wonderful. That was wonderful. Rhythm, I don't know if there's rhythm. My agent, Ruth Young, who I've been with since I was 20, always says, do one for them, do one for yourself.
这简直是在说我的语言。老实说，太棒了。等等，等等，我们试着在这里加点音乐。太棒了，那个，太棒了。等等，等等，我们试着在这里加点音乐。太棒了。那真是太棒了。节奏，我不知道这算不算节奏。我的经纪人露丝·扬（Ruth Young），我从20岁起就跟她合作，她总是说：“接一部为了钱，接一部为了自己。”
And it ends up being more of a little bit like, do like four for them and do one for yourself. If I come back and I manage to get to do theater, it has generally over the last 15 years been with Jamie Lloyd, the same director, again and again and again. And the biggest thing with theater for me is it's a risk because it's the most exposing thing you can do as an actor.
结果往往变成了更像是“接四部为了钱，接一部为了自己”。如果我回来并成功演了戏剧，在过去15年里，通常都是和杰米·劳埃德（Jamie Lloyd）合作，就是同一个导演，一次又一次。对我来说，戏剧最大的风险在于它充满了风险，因为这是作为演员你能做出的最赤裸的展示。
And you have to go up and sacrifice something every single night. and if it's shit, you're sacrificing and it's like going down like a cup of cold sick, and the audience are sitting there literally going like, or they're asleep, right? And you can fucking see it. And that kills, man, that hurts. So it's, whereas you make a movie,
你必须每晚都登台，牺牲掉一些东西。如果演得一团糟，你在做出牺牲，那种感觉就像咽下一杯冰冷的呕吐物，而观众就坐在那里，字面意思上露出……或者他们睡着了，对吧？而你他妈的能亲眼看到。这太折磨人了，老兄，这太伤人了。所以，相比之下，如果你拍了一部电影，
like the audience experience of that is like time traveling a year and a half in the future, and you're not even there like the audience experience of that is like time traveling a year and a half in the future and you're not even there. Like you can get back and you get paid like way better and it's a different thing. But it's not, it doesn't have the creative fulfillment for you, does it? It does, they both have the creative fulfillment,
观众对那部电影的体验就像是向未来穿越了一年半的时间，而你甚至都不在现场……观众对那部电影的体验就像是向未来穿越了一年半的时间，而你甚至都不在现场。就像你可以回归生活，而且片酬高得多，那是完全不同的一回事。但它并没有给你带来创意上的满足感，对吧？不，它们都有创意上的满足感，
but if I was going to be in a bad play or a bad movie, I'd rather be in a bad play. If I was going to be in a good play or a good movie, I'd rather be in a good play. What about the time to be in a good play or a good movie, I'd rather be in a good play. What about the time that it takes, the commitment you have to make ahead of time to commit to that play, rehearse, put it up, and you can't leave until it's done.
但如果要我在一部糟糕的戏剧或一部糟糕的电影里二选一，我宁愿去演一部糟糕的戏剧。如果要我在一部好戏剧或一部好电影里二选一，我宁愿去演一部好戏剧。那花费的时间呢？你必须提前做出的承诺，为了那部戏剧进行排练、上演，而且在它结束之前你都脱不开身。
Like, how many really killer jobs have you missed because you've committed to a play, and you're like, oh, fuck, had no way of knowing that script was coming? No many, actually. I've missed some killer jobs because I didn't get them. And I've missed, but then your career pans out differently and you're glad you didn't get it.
因为你已经承诺了一部戏剧，结果错过了多少真正棒极了的工作？你会不会想：“哦，操，根本没料到那个剧本会来？”其实没错过多少。我确实因为没拿到角色而错过了一些很棒的工作。我错过了一些，但随后你的职业生涯会以不同的轨迹发展，你会庆幸自己当初没拿到那个角色。
Yeah, yeah, everything got fucked up. Is there one job that you're comfortable telling us that you wish you would have gotten? Yeah, totally, totally. Which one? Deep Th Yeah, totally, totally. Which one? Deep stroke, no, I. Vroom. Vroom.
对，对，一切都搞砸了。有没有哪份工作，你现在愿意告诉我们，但你其实希望当初自己能拿下的？有的，完全有，完全有。哪一部？深喉——不，我。轰。轰。
Deep, deep. Good night Oscar. Yeah. From the Broadway show with Sean Hayes. Yeah, yeah. So I went up for Pilots of the Caribbean when I was Nezobadi. This is Orlando Bloom's part?
深，深。晚安，奥斯卡。对。来自肖恩·海斯主演的百老汇演出。对，对。所以我去试镜过《加勒比海盗》的时候我还叫... 这是奥兰多·布鲁姆的角色？
Orlando ended up getting it. It was me, I think I remember, it was a guy called Paul Nichols, and Orlando and someone else. And I don't even think Orlando was auditioning actually. I think he was off in Middle Earth doing those movies with Peter Jackson. And it was me and these two other guys who I think...
奥兰多最终得到了这个角色。当时是我，如果我没记错的话，还有一个叫保罗·尼科尔斯（Paul Nichols）的家伙，还有奥兰多以及另外某个人。其实我甚至觉得奥兰多当时都没去试镜。我觉得他当时在“中土世界”跟彼得·杰克逊一起拍那些电影。当时是我和另外两个家伙，我觉得...
Yeah, yeah, no, that's where he was. I believe it was the second film in the fellowship. Well, at that point they were in Middle Earth, of course, but you know, the precious. I believe they were in the land of Mordor where the shadows lie. Mordor. Mordor.
对，对，没错，他当时就在那儿。我相信那是《指环王》第二部的时候。嗯，当时他们确实在中土世界，当然，还有你知道的，“至尊魔戒”。我相信他们当时在充满阴影的魔多土地上。魔多。魔多。
And I went and screened camera tests. I felt like I think I got really close to it. I ended up having to do this camera test with Keira Knightley, who I later ended up doing a tournament with. Anyway, got real close to it and then it never happened. But that was one that I was like, I would get to go to sunny places and be on ships and dress like with a wig on and shoot guns that have powder that come out of them because they're muskets, man.
我去进行了银幕摄像测试。我觉得我当时离这个角色非常近。我最后不得不和凯拉·奈特莉一起做这个摄像测试，我后来还和她一起合作过一部片子。总之，离得很近了，但后来那事没成。不过那是一个让我觉得“如果成了，我就能去阳光明媚的地方，在船上待着，戴着假发打扮起来，开枪时还能射出带火药的滑膛枪，因为那是滑膛枪啊老兄”的项目。
And Johnny Depp ended up being in it and Keira was amazing. It was... And there were like five of them, right? Six of them? I know. There were like 15 of them. And I was kind of gutted about that one that I never got out.
最后约翰尼·强尼·德普演了，凯拉也很棒。那是……而且好像有大约五部吧？六部？我知道。大概有15部呢。对于没能接下那部戏，我当时心里其实挺难受的。
Right, yeah. I understand. But then my career went a different way and I was so happy with how my career went that I was very philosophical about it and like totally fine with it. But at the time, for about a year, I was like, man, the one that got away, you know? Yeah. There is one more I could tell you about. Yes, please. But I don't want to tell you about it.
对，是的。我理解。但后来我的职业生涯走了另一条路，我对自己的发展非常满意，所以我对此表现得很达观，完全释怀了。但在当时，大约有一年的时间里，我都觉得：天哪，那真是一个擦肩而过的机会啊。你知道吗？我还知道另一个可以告诉你。太好了，请讲。但我不想告诉你。
No, let's just have one more sip could tell you about. Yes, please. But I don't want to tell you about it. No, let's just have one more sip. One more sip. There was a big one. There was a big one and the director who cast me in it, I'd seen him really early in my career for a small part in a movie playing like the younger version of one of the main bad guys at the beginning of the movie. So I'd only be in it for like five, 10 minutes, but it was like an awesome part. And I came in for this audition,
不，我们再喝一口——可以告诉你。太好了，请讲。但我不想告诉你。不，我们再喝一口。再喝一口。那是一个很大的项目。那是一个很大的项目，当时把我选进组的那个导演，我在职业生涯非常早期的时候就见过他，当时是为了在一部电影里演一个小角色，在电影开头扮演其中一个主要反派的年轻版。所以我其实只出场5到10分钟，但那是个极好的角色。我来参加试镜，
and by the end of the audition, we'd shared so much life shit. He was crying, I was crying. Like the audition went amazing. The acting was like, it went great. And as I'm walking out of the room, he's like, oh my God, well, we found the guy. It's him, we found the guy.
到试镜结束时，我们已经分享了太多生活的破事。他在哭，我也在哭。试镜进展得太惊艳了。演技简直……进行得棒极了。当我走出房间时，他说：“哦天哪，威尔，我们找到我们要找的人了。就是他，我们找到这个人了。”
They never even called my agent. Christ. Wow. And then when you saw who they cast, were you like, oh, that's why I didn't get it? No. No? No.
他们甚至从来没给我经纪人打电话。天呐。哇。然后当你看到他们最终选了谁时，你会不会觉得：“哦，难怪我没选上”？没有。没有？没有。
You still didn't understand. I did not think great of their casting. However, that was like the snidiness of youth maybe. But years later, there was this big, huge, gazillion dollar movie getting made and they come to me and they go, listen, we would love you to meet so and so, this director. So I go and sit down with this director and I'm like,
你还是没搞懂。我对他们的选角并没有什么好感。不过，那也许是年轻时的尖酸刻薄吧。但多年以后，有一部超级无敌巨大的、耗资数万亿美元的电影正在筹备，他们找到我，说：“听某某说，我们很希望你能见见这个人，这位导演。”所以我去跟这位导演坐下来聊，我说：
you remember me, right? And he's like, no, have we met? I'm like, I love your work. And I'm like, no, no, no, we met. And I relay the whole story to him. And he's like, nah, don't have a single memory of that dude. Oh wow. We were in tears together you said we found the guy and looked at me as I left the room. And so did you do this big film for him or did you tell him to go fuck off? I actually did sign on to the film but it took three years and yeah I
“你还记得我，对吧？”他说：“不，我们见过吗？”我说：“我很喜欢你的作品。”然后我说：“不，不，不，我们见过的。”我把整件事的经过复述了一遍。他说：“噢，不，我对那个家伙一点印象都没有。”哦，哇。我们当时一起哭过，你说过“我们找到这个人了”，而且我离开房间时你一直看着我。所以你后来为他拍了那部大电影吗？还是你叫他滚蛋了？我确实签了这部电影，但筹备花了三年时间，然后我
was like I wasn't trying to like take him to task I was just like dude this is funny we need to talk about this. Right it took like three years to actually get it going. And by the time those three years had passed, I had a kid and this movie was being filmed in the other side of the world. And I was like, I am not going out there for a year and a half of my life to go and do whatever. Good for you.
心想，我并不是想找他算账，我只是觉得：老兄，这太逗了，我们得聊聊这事。对，差不多花了三年时间才真正开拍。等到那三年过去的时候，我已经有了孩子，而这部电影要在地球的另一端拍摄。当时我想：我才不会为了去拍个戏，花一年半的人生离开家去干那些乱七八糟的事。真为你高兴。
What does Jimmy Flough do on the side, like when he's not acting? On the side? We can talk about that, bro. he's not acting? On the side? We can talk about that, bro. Drive a cab. For free? I just get my shits.
吉姆·弗洛（Jimmy Flough）私底下都干些什么，比如不演戏的时候？私底下？我们可以聊聊这个，老兄。不演戏的时候？私底下？我们可以聊聊这个，老兄。开出租车。免费的？我只是去拉点屎。
What do I do on the side? Yeah. Do you know what? It's like being a dad and being a guy at home and I'm like- I'm working out. No, not anymore. I haven't worked out in about six months, but yeah, I was doing a lot of that before. Yeah, yeah.
我私底下都干嘛？对。你知道吗？就像当个爸爸，当个居家男人，然后我就——我在健身。不，现在不了。我大概有六个月没健身了，不过是的，我以前经常练。对，对。
Play video games with my kids. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. What about, didn't you burn one of your video games because you were too addicted to it? Wait, what? Yeah, so it's absolutely... James had a problem. I had a real problem. I don't like to talk about it, but I feel like...
跟我孩子们一起打电子游戏。哦对，对，对。等等，你是不是曾经把你的一个电子游戏给烧了，因为你对它太上瘾了？等等，什么？对，所以这绝对是……詹姆斯当时有个问题。我当时确实有个大问题。我其实不太想谈这个，但我觉得……
Let's talk about it. The more I can make people aware, maybe I had a real problem. I don't like to talk about it, but I feel like... Let's talk about it right now. The more I can make people aware, maybe I can help someone else. Yeah, why don't you help somebody out? Exactly. If one person, if you can save one person... Save a life right now. You have a little gaming issue, because I do too. I play a lot of games on my phone.
我们来聊聊吧。我越是能让人们意识到这一点，也许我当时确实有个大问题。我其实不太想谈这个，但我觉得……我们现在就来聊聊。我越是能让人们意识到这一点，也许我就能帮到别人。对，你为什么不帮帮别人呢？没错。如果一个人，如果你能拯救一个人……现在就拯救一条生命吧。你有点游戏成瘾的问题，因为我也有。我在手机上玩很多游戏。
What do you play? Oh, just the dumbest shit. No, he plays fucking Candy Crush. It's not gaming. Don't talk to him, James. He's playing Candy Crush. I played a lot of... You have serious wanker stuff, I played Call of Duty.
你玩什么？哦，就最弱智的破玩意儿。不，他他妈的玩的是《糖果粉碎传奇》（Candy Crush）。那不叫打游戏。别跟他说话，詹姆斯。他在玩《糖果粉碎传奇》。我玩过很多……你玩的是那种真正的大老爷们儿硬核游戏，我玩的是《使命召唤》（Call of Duty）。
I played Call of Duty with the same dudes for like 10 years straight, like fucking five nights a week, man, I know you're, I feel your pain. During the pandemic, I had my, my eldest son was 11 or 12, Archie, but what, how long ago was that? He was like 11 or 12. I started letting him stay up to like two in the morning to play Call of Duty with my friends and me.
我和同一帮老哥们儿连续玩了大概十年《使命召唤》，他妈的每周有五天晚上都在玩，老兄，我懂你，我能感同身受。在大流行期间，我让我的——我大儿子当时11岁或12岁，阿尔奇（Archie），但那是多久以前的事了？他当时大概11岁或12岁。我开始让他熬夜到夜里两点左右，跟我还有我的朋友们一起玩《使命召唤》。
And, and his mom calls me, she's like, he, you cannot let him stay up to like two in the morning to play Call of Duty with my friends and me. And his mom calls me, she's like, you cannot let him stay up to fucking two to play with you and your moronic friends. Right. They're not my friends. They're like, Laser Dude 6, and he's also called it. These are my comrades, these are my brothers. We're in war together, these aren't my friends.
然后，他妈妈打电话给我，说他——你绝对不能让他熬到夜里两点左右，跟我还有我的朋友们一起玩《使命召唤》。然后，他妈妈打电话给我，说：“你绝对不能让他妈的熬夜到两点去跟你还有你那些白痴朋友一起玩。”没错。他们才不是我的朋友。他们是，比如“激光老兄6号”，他也这么叫。这些是我的战友，这是我的兄弟。我们在战场上并肩作战，这些才不是我的朋友。
This is good. So you're in remission now, or are you still dabbling? I'm in remission. It started, listen, I've lapsed a couple of times. The first time I realized I had a problem, I was making a movie in Ireland with Anne Hathaway and it was called Becoming Jane. It was about Jane Austen.
这很好。所以你现在处于病情缓解期，还是说还在浅尝辄止？我处于缓解期。事情是这样的，听着，我复发过好几次。我第一次意识到自己有问题，当时我正在爱尔兰和安妮·海瑟薇拍一部电影，叫《成为简》（Becoming Jane）。讲的是简·奥斯汀的故事。
And I'm getting home every night and my wife at the time had bought me an Xbox in this fantasy role-playing game called Oblivion, The Elder Scrolls. Aptly fucking entitled Oblivion, because that's what it was taking my life. And then I remember getting home from work at like seven or eight or like nine,
我每天晚上回到家，当时的妻子给我买了一台Xbox和一款叫《上古卷轴4：湮没》（Oblivion, The Elder Scrolls）的奇幻角色扮演游戏。这游戏他妈的起名叫“湮没”（Oblivion）还真是贴切，因为这游戏正在吞噬我的人生。然后我记得那天晚上七八点或九点左右收工回家，
one of those crazy hours that you get home at in the movie business, and I order a pizza and like a two-liter bottle of Coke, Or as we call it in Scotland, a two-liter bottle of ginger. Any soft drink, fizzy soft drink can be called ginger. Ginger. Two-liter bottle of ginger and a pizza hut. And I stick in Oblivion and I go to Oblivion. And then I just remember going,
就是在电影行业里那种疯狂收工的深夜，我点了一份披萨和一大瓶两升装的可乐——或者我们在苏格兰叫它“两升装的姜汁汽水”（ginger）。任何软饮料、起泡软饮料都可以叫“姜汁汽水”。姜汁。一瓶两升装的姜汁汽水和一个必胜客披萨。然后我把《湮没》的光盘塞进主机，我就“湮没”了。接着我只记得自己当时在想：
I'll just play for five minutes more, I'll play for five minutes more. And then my driver is waiting to take me to work at 6.30 in the morning. And this is not the first time it had happened on that job either, and I was like, something has changed. And I press the eject button, and the CD comes out of the disc drive, and I go over to the gas stove,
“我再玩五分钟就好，我再玩五分钟就好。”然后我的司机在早上6点30分等著送我去上班。而且这在那份工作期间已经不是第一次发生了，当时我想：情况有变。然后我按下弹出键，光盘从光驱里退了出来，我走到煤气灶旁，
and I turn on the gas stove, and I'm standing there like this, going like, how am I gonna fall in love with Jane Austen today? And I'm like, like, how am I going to fall in love with Jane Austen? And I'm like... Because you know, and then I just drop it on the gas stove and I just watch it melt. And then I walked away. That's a bottom. Yeah, I mean it's a real thing.
我打开煤气灶，然后就这样站在那儿，心想：我今天该怎么跟简·奥斯汀坠入爱河啊？我心想——就像是，我该怎么跟简·奥斯汀坠入爱河啊？我心想……因为你知道的，然后我直接把它扔在煤气灶上，眼睁睁看着它融化。然后我走开了。那是他人生的谷底。对，我的意思是这确实是个很严重的问题。
And your bottom is only when you decide to stop digging, you know what I mean? Yeah. But the pandemic, I had the same thing as you, man. I had like three buddies. We all went, hey guys, should we just get like a... Should we all get like a PS4 or something like that? And we're like, we'll all play some shooting game. Until like two years later.
而你的人生谷底只有当你决定停止向下挖的时候才会到来，你知道我的意思吗？对。但在疫情期间，我和你遇到了同样的情况，老兄。我有差不多三个死党。我们当时都说：“嘿，伙计们，我们要不要去买个……要不要一起买个PS4什么的？”然后我们说：“大家一起玩点射击游戏。”直到大约两年后。
And we're like, John, John, I'm going in! I'm going in, man! Bite me up! Bite me! Push! Push! Push! Push! It got... I know. he got so fucking crazy. And then I recently had one of my friends say, hey, we're still playing. I'm like, no, I'm never going, I can't do it, man.
我们还在喊：“约翰，约翰，我要冲了！我要冲了，老兄！拉我一把！拉我！冲！冲！冲！冲！”这变得……我知道。这他妈太疯狂了。然后最近我有个朋友说：“嘿，我们还在玩呢。”我说：“不，我再也不去了，我做不到，老兄。”
Not right now. I think I'm the last man standing. I'm the last guy still playing. You are. You are still playing. So you managed to find the right size for it. The right size for my addiction? Yeah, I mean, you're not staying up until dawn anymore, are you?
现在不行。我觉得我是最后一个还活着的人。我是最后一个还在玩的人。确实是你。你还在玩。所以你设法找到了控制它的合适度。我成瘾的合适度？对，我的意思是，你已经不再熬夜到天亮了吧？
No, no, no, no, no, there had to be a cap. Do you know what, to be honest, I came back from a job in Germany where I did a lot of it because I was just on my own and I didn't have my family with me and that was quite good and I bought a little laptop to make it portable. But since I've come home and I'm getting into prep and I'm casting and I'm working on the script and all that, there's just no time for it. Yeah, it's all good. make it portable. But since I've come home and I'm getting into prep and I'm casting and I'm working on the script and all that, there's just no time for it. And actually, it's been kind of good.
不，不，不，不，不，必须得设个上限。你知道吗，老实话，我从德国的一份工作回来，在那儿我玩得很疯，因为我孤身一人，家人不在身边，那段时光挺不错的，我还买了一台小笔记本电脑以便随身携带。但自从我回了家，开始投入筹备工作，开始选角，开始修改剧本以及所有这些杂务之后，就根本没时间玩了。对，一切都挺好的。以便随身携带。但自从我回了家，开始投入筹备工作，开始选角，开始修改剧本以及所有这些杂务之后，就根本没时间玩了。而且实际上，这感觉还挺不错的。
Because it's time to be an adult at 45. What game is it that you're... Call of Duty, man. Yeah, that's great. Call of Duty. Like, during the pandemic, it was running around for dance, getting killed by 12-year-old guys in China. How crazy was that when they did that first,
因为45岁了，是时候当个成年人了。你玩的是什么游戏……《使命召唤》，老兄。对，太棒了。《使命召唤》。你看，在大流行期间，就是在韦尔丹斯克（Verdansk）到处跑，被中国的12岁小孩爆头。当时他们第一次搞那个的时候有多疯狂，
what do they call that, the big map that they dropped during the pandemic, the fucking... Verdansk. Yeah, it was fucking crazy, wasn't it? It was crazy, it was so good. But within a month, those kids were so good at sniping that you couldn't even last for a minute, like you'd land and you'd be dead.
他们管那个叫什么来着，就是大流行期间他们放出的那个大地图，他妈的……韦尔丹斯克。对，当时他妈的太疯狂了，对吧？太疯狂了，真的太棒了。但不到一个月的时间，那些小孩的狙击技术已经好到你连一分钟都撑不下去了，你刚落地就得死。
We were bad at that game for two years. My squad and I, we were, what was the name, you'd land and you'd be dead. We were bad at that game for two years. My squad and I, we were, what was the name, it was K-Chuck, there was, because it was the pandemic, one of them named themselves Touch of Flu, and then, and then the other one was Severe Shock O, and I was Walker Janeway, which is a character I played
我们在那个游戏里菜了两年。我和我的小队，我们是，叫什么名字来着，你刚落地就会死。我们在那个游戏里菜了两年。我和我的小队，我们是，叫什么名字来着，是K-Chuck，还有，因为当时是大流行，其中一个人给自己取名叫“流感触感”（Touch of Flu），然后，然后另一个人叫“严重休克”（Severe Shock O），而我叫沃克·简维（Walker Janeway），那是我演过的一个角色
in a kind of a middle class New York play once. And there's people around going like, I'm going to kill you Severe Shock-O, I'm going to kill you Touch of Flu and then going, I'm going to get you Walker Janeway? Yeah. It was so good, it was like so bougie. But yeah, no, it was, and And you know what I found as well, right? I've been pals with those guys since my early 20s, and what was really special about it was that we'd be running around going like, push, push, push, I'm going in, fucking hell, John, support me!
有一次在纽约演一部中产阶级的戏剧。台下的人都在喊：我要杀了你，“重度休克”、我要杀了你，“流感触电”，然后又喊：我要抓住你，“沃克·詹恩威”？对啊。太棒了，简直讲究得不行。不过说真的，而且你知道我发现什么了吗？我从二十出头就和那些家伙是好朋友了，最特别的是，我们会到处跑着喊：推、推、推，我要进去了，他妈的，约翰，支援我！
So when did you say that you got that procedure done? Oh, my God, that's interesting. I never knew that about you, and we were just like... in a way we never had. Yeah, you know what? It's funny you say that as much as I sort of rail against it too And I do love gaming is that I stayed connected to a lot of guys. We have this crew of us the clown crew We're still in a run a text chain that we've been on since 2007
那你刚才说你是什么时候做那个手术的？哦，天哪，真有意思。我以前对你一点都不知道，然后我们就……以一种前所未有的方式。对啊，你知道吗？说实话挺有意思的，尽管我有时也挺反感这玩意的，而且我也确实挺喜欢打游戏的，但我跟很多哥们一直保持着联系。我们有个小团体叫“小丑帮”，我们到现在还在用一个从2007年就开始聊的群聊呢。
In that we all play this game together and these guys know and Jason especially knows because we did a few things in the gaming Thing and it's like me and Giles, who goes by Kid Lightning, and Mark, who goes by Forman Beast, he's known as Beast to all of us. They all call me Wendell, because my handle is Wendell Leaf, because it's named after my favorite hockey player. And we've had so many moments.
在这个群里我们经常一起打游戏，大家也都知道，尤其是杰森，因为我们一起参与过一些跟游戏相关的事。我和吉尔斯（游戏ID叫“闪电小子”）、还有马克（游戏ID叫“野兽福尔曼”，我们大家都叫他“野兽”）。他们都叫我温德尔，因为我的游戏ID叫“温德尔·利夫”，是用我最喜欢的冰球运动员的名字命名的。我们有过太多难忘的时刻了。
I was texting with the guys this morning, our buddy Jerry, who we also call Gary, for no reason. Gary just had his second kid, and we're all congratulating him on the thing, and we all know Gary for no reason, Gary just had his second kid and we're all congratulating him on the thing and we all know each other from the gaming thing. So there is a community thing, it's really, it's quite nice. I don't know if you remember, Will,
我今天早上还在跟大伙发信息，我们的死党杰瑞（我们有时也无缘无故叫他加里）。加里刚刚有了他的第二个孩子，我们都在祝贺他这件大喜事，而且我们大家其实都是因为打游戏才认识的。所以这里面确实有一种社区般的氛围，真的，感觉挺不错的。我不知道你记不记得，威尔，
you try to get me, like years and years and years ago, try to get me in one of those groups, I played for maybe seven minutes. Yes, briefly. I couldn't exit the thing, I just would get shot like every single time right away and I couldn't figure out like, so let's get shot like right every single time right away. And I couldn't figure out like, so let's try it again, let's try it again.
你好多年、好多年、好多年以前，想拉我进那种群组，结果我玩了大概七分钟吧。对，就一会儿。我都不知道怎么退出那个游戏，反正我一进去马上就得挨枪子儿，而且我压根搞不懂——怎么一上来马上就得挨枪子儿。我琢磨不透，就想说：那我们再试一次吧，再试一次。
And we'd start again and I'd come out with these guns and everybody just bang, bang, bang, bang, bang. Like I'd just be dead in two seconds. It was awful. But it is a good way to connect and that's that part of it. I do like that part of it for sure. We were so bad at it for two solid years. We never got any better and it was a lot of fun.
然后我们重新开始，我拿着枪出来，结果所有人就是砰、砰、砰、砰、砰。两秒钟之内我就挂了。太惨了。不过这确实是一种联络感情的好方式，这部分我挺喜欢的。我真的很喜欢这方面的氛围。我们连续两年菜得抠脚。技术从来没见长过，但真的超级好玩。
We laughed our asses off. I love that. Well James, you're a lot of fun. We've laughed our asses off with you today. We sure have. We appreciate your time, my friend. Very nice to get to know you. Huge fans of yours.
我们笑得肚子都快痛死了。我太喜欢了。詹姆斯，你真的太逗了。今天和你在一起我们也笑得肚子疼。确实如此。非常感谢你抽空来做客，我的朋友。很高兴认识你。我们都是你的超级粉丝。
It's really cool to meet you. I have a great time directing. Yes, I talk about you all the time. I just think you're an incredible actor. Incredible. Speak No Evil, out now. It is from the great Jason Blum. Directed, written by James Watkins, everybody.
很高兴能见到你。我非常享受执导的过程。对，我经常提起你。我觉得你是个了不起的演员。太了不起了。《非礼勿言》，现已上映。本片由伟大的杰森·布鲁姆倾力打造。导演兼编剧是詹姆斯·沃特金斯，各位。
Speak No Evil, check it out. Go and see it. Jimmy Frow, thanks Jimmy Frow. Jimmy Flow. Jimmy Fl out. Go and see it. Yeah, Jimmy Flau. Thanks, Jimmy Flau. Jimmy Flau. Jimmy Flau with the Hatchings Macamor. Thanks, you guys. Guys, thanks a million.
《非礼勿言》，大家快去看看。去看吧。吉米·弗劳，谢谢你，吉米·弗劳。吉米·弗洛。吉米·Fl出。去看吧。对，吉米·弗劳。谢谢你，吉米·弗劳。吉米·弗劳。吉米·弗劳和哈奇斯·麦卡摩。谢谢你们，伙计们。伙计们，太感谢了。
Seriously, love your stuff. And as performers, actors, writers, directors, you're fucking amazing, the three of you. Thank you. It was really, really great to meet you, my friend. Thank you. See you around, guys. Cheers, bye-bye.
说真的，我很喜欢你们的作品。作为表演者、演员、作家、导演，你们三个真是牛逼极了。谢谢。很高兴能见到你，我的朋友。谢谢。回头见，伙计们。保重，拜拜。
Thank you, James. Bye, buddy. Wow. Hey, guys. All right, guys. Cheers, bye-bye. Thank you, James. Bye, buddy. Wow. Hey, guys. Yeah. We're back. We're back from commercial. Hi.
谢谢你，詹姆斯。再见，老兄。哇。嘿，伙计们。好了，伙计们。保重，拜拜。谢谢你，詹姆斯。再见，老兄。哇。嘿，伙计们。对。我们回来了。广告播完了，我们回来了。嗨。
Do we do commercial after? No, we don't. We don't. Do you remember hearing a commercial play? You were just, he just hung up. Right, right, right, right, right. So guys, that was James McAvoy. And you know what, I gotta tell you,
我们刚才播广告了吗？没有，我们没播。你记得听到过广告吗？你刚才——他刚挂断电话。对，对，对，对，对。所以各位，刚才那位就是詹姆斯·麦卡沃伊。而且你知道吗，我得说，
I'm not buying the accent. I think he needs to work on that. Yeah, really, you don't think it's? Yeah, I mean, everyone knows he's from Dayton, Ohio, and he's been working on the Scottish things. Dayton, Ohio. Yeah, no, he's great, though. I didn't ask him about Narnia
我对他的口音持保留意见。我觉得他在这方面还得练练。是吗，真的吗，你觉得不像吗？对啊，谁都知道他是俄亥俄州代顿市人，他一直在努力练习苏格兰口音。代顿市，俄亥俄州。好吧，不过他真的很棒。我没有问他关于纳尼亚的事，
and like, Lion, the Witch and the wardrobe. I was obsessed with that book. Or X-Men, I mean, what's the matter with you? I know, I know. I'm not like a massive X-Men thing. Like, I think he's great. Walk us through it though. What's missing for you with that? No, I like it.
比如《狮子、女巫和魔衣橱》。我以前对那本书着迷得不行。还有《X战警》，我是说，你脑子有病吧？我知道，我知道。我又不是那种超级狂热的《X战警》迷。不过，我觉得他演得很好。你还是给我们讲讲吧。在你看来，他身上还欠缺了点什么？不，我挺喜欢他的。
It's just, I just never, it's hooked into it. I mean, I watched them all and they're great. I just, I'm not a rabid fan of the series. But yeah, the Narnia things, I wish they, those that personal was so great. Was it the wardrobe that you didn't like or the witch? No, so he played the fawn, what was his name? The fawns.
只是我从来没有，没有完全被它迷住。我的意思是，那些电影我都看过了，也都很棒。只是我算不上这个系列的死忠粉。不过说真的，关于纳尼亚的那些东西，我真希望它们，那些个体的感受真是太棒了。你是不喜欢那个衣橱还是不喜欢那个女巫？不，他演的是那个半羊人，他叫什么名字来着？半羊人。
Tumnus, Mr. Tumnus? Tummy sticks. Something like that. And didn't you guys like that book when you were a kid? Of course. I never read it. Oh, it was the best. Of course, I read the whole series.
图纳斯，图纳斯先生？小肚子。差不多吧。你们小时候难道不喜欢那本书吗？当然喜欢。我从来没读过。哦，那简直是神作。当然了，我把整个系列都读完了。
They were fucking great. Yeah, so great books. Great books. But anyway, I didn't get a chance to ask him. When he popped on, I was like, oh, I've actually always wanted to meet him. And so I got to meet him. Who wrote those books?
它们太他妈棒了。对啊，太棒的书了。好书。不过话说回来，我刚才没机会问他。他一连线我就在想：哦，其实我一直很想见他。所以我终于见到他了。那些书是谁写的？
Quick. C.S. Lewis. Nice. Yeah, thanks. Hey, Willie, are you still doing that book club thing? Yeah. When's that launching? Book club with myself.
快说。C·S·刘易斯。不错。对，谢谢。嘿，威利，你还在搞那个读书俱乐部吗？对啊。什么时候上线？我自己搞的读书俱乐部。
I don't know, we are going to do, yeah, we are going to be launching the Smart List. It's been a time thing, but we are going to do the Smart List Book Club. Yeah, because if you mention a book, I will read it and we can talk about it. Yeah, yeah. And JB, thank you for sending us over those book recos
我不知道，我们打算做，对，我们准备推出“聪明人书单”。时间上有点赶，但我们确实要搞个“聪明人读书俱乐部”。对啊，因为只要你提到一本书，我就会去读，然后我们可以一起讨论。对，对。还有JB，谢谢你发给我们那些书单推荐，
from your pal, from Laura, which is always nice to get book recos. Yeah, because you don't want to, it's like television recos or movie stuff. Yeah, it's hard to fucking narrow it down. There's so many fucking books out there. And I'm assuming that- James kind of looks like if Heath Ledger
来自你的朋友劳拉，能收到书单推荐总是让人高兴的。对啊，因为你不想去……这就跟电视推荐或者电影推荐一样。对啊，要缩小范围他妈的太难了。外面有成千上万本好书呢。而且我觉得——詹姆斯长得有点像希斯·莱杰
had a baby with Jude Law. Right, you know, I was thinking he looks a lot like Josh Charles, our friend Josh Charles. Do you guys know Josh? Oh, he does remind me of Josh Charles, certainly. Josh Charles, Baltimore Orioles fan, incredible actor. Well, because he's from Baltimore. He's a wonderful bloke.
和裘德·洛生出来的孩子。对哦，我还觉得他长得很像乔什·查尔斯，我们的朋友乔什·查尔斯。你们认识乔什吗？哦，他确实让我想起了乔什·查尔斯。乔什·查尔斯，巴尔的摩金莺队的球迷，一位了不起的演员。对，因为他是巴尔的摩人。他是个绝妙的家伙。
He is a wonderful bloke. Do they say bloke in Scotland? No, they don't, but you know what, that's okay. I think they might sometimes. That McEvoy, that Jimmy Flo, is that what we're calling him? Jimmy Flo. Jimmy Flo. Yeah, he's got something about him, doesn't he?
他确实是个绝妙的家伙。苏格兰人也用“家伙”（bloke）这个词吗？不，他们不用，不过你知道吗，这没关系。我觉得他们有时可能也会用。那个麦卡沃伊，那个“吉米·弗洛”，这是我们给他起的外号吗？吉米·弗洛。吉米·弗洛。对啊，他身上确实有一种独特的魅力，不是吗？
He's just cool, he's very down to earth. He's got a real sort of authenticity to him, which I really respond to. You like the cut of his chip? I very much like the cut of his chip. You could hang out with that guy. I could hang out with that guy, yeah, he's really cool. We would hang, we would do some hard hanging.
他就是很酷，非常脚踏实地。他有一种非常真实的原生态感，这让我很有共鸣。你很欣赏他的作风吗？我非常欣赏他的作风。你可以跟那种人一起厮混。我绝对能跟那种人厮混，对，他太酷了。我们会一起玩，进行一些硬核的厮混。
And every single time he plays. I have a lot of comments for people who walk by. You know what I mean? A lot of like, look at this fucking guy. You know what I mean? My favorite shit. Every time he plays a different character, I totally... There we go.
而且他每次演戏的时候。我对那些路过的人有很多意见。你知道我的意思吗？有很多诸如“瞧瞧这混蛋”之类的话。你知道吧？我最喜欢这出戏了。每次他扮演不同的角色，我都完全……好了。
Buy it! We really snuck that one up on a shiny boy. Nice going. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
买下它！我们真是在这小伙子身上搞了个突然袭击。干得漂亮。聪明。伶俐。聪明。伶俐。聪明。伶俐。聪明。伶俐。聪明伶俐（SmartLess）节目100%由有机原料制成，并由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆杰夫手工匠造。
Smart. Less. So Jason and Willie, we have a new show on Smartless Media called Goal. That I'm very, very excited. Sorry, I just cut off when you said the title, Goal-less. Goal-less, right. Now Sean and I are excited about it too, but here's what's good. Sean and I are much more sort of like the, a bit more of the typical American audience that does not know as much about soccer as you do. So you have taken that into account
聪明。伶俐。所以杰森和威利，我们在“聪明人传媒”推出了一档新节目叫《进球者》（Goalis），对此我感到非常、非常兴奋。抱歉，刚才你一说节目名字《无球可进》（Goal-less），我就卡壳了。《无球可进》，对吧。现在肖恩和我对此也很兴奋，不过棒就棒在：肖恩和我更像是那种典型的美国观众，对足球的了解远不如你们那么深。所以你们在筹备这档播客的方式时，已经把这一点考虑进去了，对吧？
with the way in which you've gone about developing this podcast, yes? Well I brought in, I wanted to introduce you guys to the great, the best Howard. Yeah, Russell. Hello. Russell Howard. The greatest. Yeah, Russell. Our host. Russell Howard, Russell Howard, hello, hello. Russell Howard, here he is.
对，我把——我想把最好的霍华德介绍给各位。对，拉塞尔。你好。拉塞尔·霍华德。最棒的。对，拉塞尔。我们的主持人。拉塞尔·霍华德，拉塞尔·霍华德，你好，你好。拉塞尔·霍华德，他来啦。
Yes. Russ, here, so, Russell, I'm going to let you describe Goalist because football is my soccer, whatever you want to call it is my passion, I love it, but you are our host because you are even more passionate and have grown up in this milieu. Go ahead, Russell Howard. And also, by the way, from my sister Tracy,
对。拉塞尔，来吧——所以，拉塞尔，我要让你来形容一下《进球者》，因为足球——我的意思是英式足球，或者你管它叫什么——是我的挚爱，我热爱它。但你是我们的主持人，因为你对它有着更深的狂热，而且是在这种环境中长大的。请吧，拉塞尔·霍华德。顺便说一句，还有我姐姐特雷西，
one of the most successful stand-up comedians in the UK. And not related to Ron. No, just to be clear. Just to be clear. Not related to Ron. Yeah, I'm a stand-up comedian from England. And I was, thank you, thank you. I was given the opportunity to do this podcast
她是英国最成功的单口喜剧演员之一。而且跟朗·霍华德没亲戚关系。对，声明一下。把话说清楚。跟朗·霍华德没有亲戚关系。对，我是一个来自英格兰的单口喜剧演员。我当时——谢谢你们，谢谢。我得到了这个机会来做这档关于足球的播客，
about football, and basically, it's gonna be like a late night sort of show about soccer, football, whatever you want to call it. We're going to talk about the Champions League. We're going to be interviewing ex-pros, current pros, celebrities of the life, football. It's everything you can imagine. Do you have a band?
基本上，它会是一个类似于深夜秀的节目，聊的全是关于足球、英式足球或者无论你怎么称呼它的运动。我们要聊欧冠联赛。我们还会采访退役球员、现役球员以及足球界的各路名流。你能想象到的应有尽有。你们有乐队吗？
I don't have a band, no. We'll get you one of those. Okay. We'll get you one of those. A. We'll get you one of those. And a high hat. Imagine that, if that's the first complaint of the show, it's good. There's a lot of funny chat about football. But where's the band?
我没有乐队，没有。我们会给你配一个的。好吧。我们会给你配一个的。A。我们会给你配一个的。还要一个爵士鼓镲。想象一下，如果这是节目的第一个槽点，那也挺好的。节目里有很多关于足球的趣味闲聊。不过乐队在哪呢？
Could use a band. You're going to talk about Champions League. Now Jason and Sean, Champions League is the tournament that they do yearly of all the top, basically, in essence, the top four teams from all the domestic leagues all over Europe in The UK play against each other in midweek games throughout the year and finally in the spring they narrow it down They start in group play then they get into elimination and well and by the way Russell will has got me excited about soccer. So I actually have to Yes, champions league football is incredible at some point though at some point
倒是可以整个乐队。你们要聊欧冠。杰森和肖恩，欧冠联赛就是他们每年举办的赛事，参赛的全是那些顶级球队——基本上，也就是全欧洲各个国内联赛的前四名球队。在一年中的周中进行比赛，最后在春天决出胜负。他们先从小组赛开始，然后进入淘汰赛，而且——顺便说一句，拉塞尔，威尔已经把我对足球的热情给点燃了。所以我其实必须得——对，欧冠联赛真是精彩绝伦。不过在某个时刻，在某个时刻，
We're gonna have to figure out so you don't have to keep saying soccer I mean football over and over we have to figure out what to call them. But anyway, I'll call it soccer for you people I don't mind. All right, just at home. I can't if I say football It's you know, but this podcast can be listened to all over the world though, right? So what do you... Do you prioritize the American audience, the global audience? What do you do? I don't know, Jason. It's a very difficult one. We'll wait to see the numbers.
我们得想个办法，这样你就不用一直说“英式足球”了。我的意思是，为了避免翻来覆去地重复，我们得商量一下到底该怎么称呼它。不过无所谓，为了你们这些美国人，我还是叫它“soccer”好了，我没意见。行吧，就按你们习惯的来。我要是说“football”，你知道的……不过这档播客全世界的人都能听到，对吧？所以你们……你们是更优先考虑美国观众，还是全球观众？你们到底怎么打算的？
Whoever listens, gets soccer or football. By the way, the way Russell said, I don't know, Jason, that sounds like some PA on Jason's set when he's like, what's for lunch? Blah, blah, blah. And they're like, I don't know Jason. Just fucking leave me alone. There's a lot of dips, Jason. We know we've been through this when we had David Beckham on.
我不知道，杰森。这可真是个难题。我们得等收听数据出来再说。
I think we were talking about, you know that soccer is actually an English term. Yeah. So you know this. Well exactly, but it was whatever we want to call it. I can't call it soccer. It would be like calling my mum mummy. It just feels, it gives me the ick. But you know what, the British accent covers you. I think any time you say football, people are going to think you mean soccer
不管是哪里的听众，只要听了，就能懂什么是英式足球。顺便说一句，拉塞尔刚刚那句“我不知道，杰森”，听起来就像杰森片场里的某个制片助理，当杰森问“午饭吃什么”时，支支吾吾的那种语气。然后他们就会说：“我不知道啊，杰森。求求你他妈别烦我了。”这里面有很多潜规则，杰森。我们知道的，当年大卫·贝克汉姆来做客的时候我们就经历过这些。
because you're saying with a British accent. Exactly. And we'll just be, it's like, not only do I love football, but it's such an innately funny sport. Like the supporters are hilarious. I don't know if you too, if you've never been to a live football game in England, if you go, you're just being, oh, it's the best. I like this singing.
我想我们当时在讨论，你知道“soccer”其实是一个地道的英国词汇吗？对。所以你是知道这一点的。完全没错，但管它叫什么呢。我可没法叫它“soccer”。这就好像叫我妈咪“妈咪”一样。感觉怪怪的，让我起一身鸡皮疙瘩。不过你知道吗，英国口音能帮你掩饰过去。我觉得只要你说“football”，大家都会以为你指的是足球，
How do you learn, is there a website you can go to to learn the chants before you get to a game? That's such a good point, because it, like, they must meet up in a pub and home and all that. So there must be like football hooligans who are sort of sat there in a council flat going, look to me for the changes, here we go. You're going home in a fucking ambulance.
因为你的发音带有英国口音。完全正确。我们到时候就会——这就好像，我不仅热爱足球，而且这项运动本身就自带强烈的幽默感。比如那些球迷简直太搞笑了我不知道你们俩——如果你们从来没有在英国现场看过一场足球比赛的话，要是去了，你们就会觉得——哦，这简直太棒了。我喜欢这种合唱。
Come on, all together. When I listen to Goalist, I want to learn about these things. I want you to take care of the dingbats like me too. You know, not just the smarties like Will. Russell, you're a Reds fan, you're a Liverpool supporter. I am a Liverpool fan, yeah. Same here, hardcore. I'm newer obviously to it, it's only been 10 years for me.
你们是怎么学会的？有没有哪个网站可以让你在去看球之前先学会那些助威歌词？这真是个好问题，因为——这帮人肯定是在某个酒吧里聚会，不管是主场还是别的什么地方。所以肯定有一些足球流氓坐在某个经济适用房里，一边喝着酒一边说：“听我的口令换歌词，我们上。你他妈得坐着救护车回家了。”
Oh wow. So what was your in? What was your in? My friend of the podcast, Chappie, Mark Chappell, he lives in London. Here's the Chappie mention. He got me into it like 10 years ago when we were working together and I've become full. And I, you know, now look, I'm into Arne Slott.
来吧，大家一起唱。当我收听《进球者》的时候，我想了解这些东西。我也希望你们能照顾照顾像我这样的白痴。你知道的，不仅仅是像威尔那种聪明人。拉塞尔，你是个红军球迷，你是利物浦的死忠。我是利物浦球迷，对。我也是，铁杆球迷。显然我是后来才入坑的，我粉利物浦才十年。
I'm so happy he's there. But Jurgen Klopp has been my hero, my North Star for years now. I had the opportunity to hang out with him a couple of times in the last few years. He's been a coach, it's been incredible. Yeah, and I've gone out of my way to learn some of the songs, some of He's a coach. Wow. It's just been incredible. Yeah. And I've gone out of my way to learn some of the songs, some of the like, you know,
哦，哇。那你是怎么入坑的？你是怎么被带进这个圈子的？我的播客好友查皮，马克·查佩尔，他住在伦敦。瞧，查皮被cue到了。大约十年前我们在合作时，他把我带进了这个圈子，然后我就彻底沦陷了。而且，我现在——你看，我很崇拜阿内·斯洛特。
we conquered all of Europe. We're never going to stop. We're never going to stop. From Paris down to Turkey. We've won the fucking lot. We've won the fucking lot. Who will write this? Bob Paisley and Bill Shankly.
我太高兴他能来执教了。但尤尔根·克洛普多年来一直我的英雄，是我的指路明灯。过去几年我有幸跟他一起厮混过好几次。他曾是一位教练，这简直太不可思议了。对啊，而且我不遗余力地去学习一些歌曲，学习一些，你知道的……
Oh, he knows it. Let's do it. The Fields of Anfield Road. We are loyal supporters. And we come from Liverpool. Now, how do you learn this, Will? Is this on a website? Like, how do you learn this?
我们征服了整个欧洲。我们永不停歇。我们永不停歇。从巴黎到土耳其。我们赢下了他妈的一切。我们赢下了他妈的一切。是谁写了这首歌？鲍勃·佩斯利和比尔·香克利。
I mean, I've been on the internet for a while. I've been on the internet for a while. I've been on the internet for a while. I've been on the internet for a while. I've been on the internet for a while. I've been on the internet for a while. We are Lord Supporters and we come from Liverpool. Now how do you learn this, Will? Is it on a website? Like how do you... Yeah, you can look up... Yeah, because you're like... What I love most about it is it clearly is on a website. But there's the fact that Will Arnett has clearly been in his shower.
噢，他全知道。我们来一段。安菲尔德路的球场。我们是忠实的拥趸。我们来自利物浦。那么，威尔，你是怎么学会这些的？这玩意儿在哪个网站上有吗？你到底是怎么……对啊，你可以去查……对啊，因为你就像……我最喜欢的一点是，这很显然是在某个网站上能查到的。但事实是威尔·阿内特显然一直在他的淋浴间里，
Practicing it. Yeah, of course you have. Who gets to decide what songs are going to be sung on what week? Like do they get changed? Because, and they're often really funny. I remember there's a brilliant story of the Rangers goalkeeper Andy Gorham, who basically came out and said he was a schizophrenic. And his own crowd that week started chanting,
偷偷练习唱这个。对啊，你当然练过。到底是谁来决定每星期该唱什么歌的？这些歌会换吗？而且，这些歌通常都非常搞笑。我记得有个特别精彩的故事，讲的是流浪者队的门将安迪·戈勒姆，他公开向公众坦白说自己患有精神分裂症。结果那周他们自己的球迷就在看台上高喊：
there's only two Andy Gorhams, two Andy Gorhams. So that's what I mean. With football, there's sort of like this sort of galaxy around it that is sort of just naturally piss-taking. Like some of the best moments at a football game happen with the crowd. Like footballers get abused. Like, and I'm a stand-up comedian. The heckles you get are nothing compared to footballers.
“场上只有一个安迪·戈勒姆，两个安迪·戈勒姆。”所以这就是我想说的。足球周围存在着一种天然的宇宙，到处都是这种自嘲的恶作剧。球场上最精彩的时刻往往是由球迷创造的。那些足球运动员经常遭到各种辱骂。而且我还是个单口喜剧演员。我收到的嘘声跟足球运动员挨的骂比起来根本不算什么。
I remember seeing, I went to a Bath City game. I don't know if I can, this is, there was maybe about 500 people there. Yeah. It was boxing day and they were, it was a pre-match warm-up and the goalkeeper was quite a heavy set lad and he was just getting one of the balls out of the net. And he looked at this kid who must have been about 11 and he said, did you have a good Christmas?
我记得有一次，我去观看了一场巴斯城队的比赛。我不知道我能不能讲这个——当时现场大概有500人左右。对。那是节礼日，当时正在进行赛前热身，那个守门员是个身材挺魁梧的小伙子，他正弯腰从球网里捡球。然后他看着一个顶多十一岁的小男孩问：你圣诞节过得开心吗？
And this little kid went, looks like you did, you fat cunt. And... And there is no world in which that's allowed. Like, this poor guy just had to take it from an 11-year-old kid. And it's that just viciousness. This is the kind of flavor and spice we want to get from you on a weekly basis. Yes.
结果这个小男孩回了一句：“看你那体型，你过得挺滋润啊，你这个大胖子。”然后……没有任何一个世界会允许这种事情发生。这个可怜家伙只能默默忍受一个十一岁小孩的辱骂。就是这种恶毒劲儿。这正是我们希望你每周在节目里带给我们的风味和佐料。对的。
It was so fascinating and if you've never been to a football game, I remember taking my wife to watch Liverpool Paris Saint-Germain and she was just fascinated. All the sort of French football fans took their tops off and they were kind of swinging them around and it's like this weird church that just goes crazy on a European night. So basically that's what the podcast is doing. I love that and it's growing and growing and growing. What's so crazy is I was going to say that, sorry Sean, but I was going to say that kind of vibe that you get, I remember, like I said, I remember a lot, just a couple months ago
这太迷人了，如果你从来没去现场看过足球比赛的话，我记得带我老婆去看利物浦对阵巴黎圣日耳曼的比赛时，她整个人都看呆了。所有那些法国球迷都脱掉上衣，在头顶疯狂地挥舞着，那种感觉就像是一个狂热的欧战之夜里陷入疯狂的奇异教堂。所以基本上，这就是我们这档播客要做的事情。我太喜欢这个概念了，而且它正变得越来越火爆。最疯狂的是，我本来想说——抱歉肖恩，我本想说那种你所能感受到的氛围，我记得——就像我刚才说的，我记得就在几个月前，
I was at Anfield and sitting and watching, maybe I told you guys this story, watching Sir Kenneth Dogg, they're sitting right behind me with his wife and how many times they've been to Anfield, he was as a player and a manager, blah, blah, blah, and them singing, You'll Never Walk Alone.
我还坐在安菲尔德球场观看比赛，也许我跟你们讲过这个故事，我看到肯尼·达格利什爵士和他的妻子就坐在我身后，他们去安菲尔德的次数数不胜数，无论是作为球员还是作为主教练，诸如此类，然后全场高唱着《你永远不会独行》。
Never Walk Alone. And his wife dabbing her eyes. It's so moved by it. Well, he's an incredible man as well. He's incredible. To get serious, the Hillsborough disaster where a lot of Liverpool supporters died, he went to every single funeral when he was the manager.
永远不会独行。他的妻子正用纸巾拭泪。感动得无以复加。嗯，他也是个了不起的人。太了不起了。说点严肃的，当年发生希尔斯堡惨案时，许多利物浦球迷不幸遇难，身为球队主帅的他出席了每一场葬礼。
Yeah, every single one. And so the club is, you know, it's in his bones. So I think that song, you know, really takes him to a special place. It is beautiful and the whole stadium sings it. By the way, we're sitting there and the stand opposite us is the Sir Kenneth Douglass stand. And he's sitting right behind me. It's just incredible.
对，每一场都去了。所以这家俱乐部，你知道的，已经彻底融入他的骨血里了。所以我觉得那首歌，真的能把他带到一个非常特殊的精神世界。这首歌真的很美，而且整个体育场的人都在齐声合唱。顺便说一句，我们当时坐在那儿，对面看台就是肯尼·达格利什爵士看台。而他本人就坐在我身后。简直太不可思议了。
But he's a bit harsh that they don't let him sit in his own stand. I know. No. No, it's better. It's better. He gets to look at it. He gets to look at it You know Jason and I shared an office once and I'd had and I was exciting and it was a big long office and I Had this huge painting from a show. I wasn't there a lot and I had this huge He's give me shit and I'd be like I don't want to be in the fuck We had this I had this huge painting of myself from a show and one day when he was there
不过他们不让他坐在自己的专属看台上，这未免有点太严苛了吧。我知道。不。不，这样更好。这样更好。他可以转头看着它。他可以看着它……你知道，我和杰森曾经共用过一个办公室，当时我有一间——那是一间又长又大的办公室，我有一幅从某个节目里拿来的巨大海报。我不经常去那儿，但我有这么大一幅……他一直在取笑我，我会说：我可不想他妈的待在……我们当时有这个——我有一幅自己在大获成功的一档节目中的巨幅画像，有一天他正好在那儿，
I hadn't put it behind my desk, behind where I sat. And so he called me one day and he goes, why did they put this fucking painting of you on? I go, because when I'm not there, you still get to look at me. Yeah. I remember doing that years ago. I had loads of kind of posters of various stand-up shows that I'd done.
我还没把它挂在我的办公桌后面、我常坐的那个位置后面。所以有一天他给我打电话说：“他们为什么要把你这幅该死的画像挂在这儿？”我说：“因为就算我不在，你依然能看着我。”对啊。我记得多年前我也干过这种事。我当时手里有很多各种自己演过的单口喜剧演出的海报。
And I kind of thought, what would be a nice thing to have them? And then I put them up in this room in my house. posters of various stand-up shows that I'd done. And I kind of thought, what would be a nice thing to have them? And then I put them up in this room in my house, and then as soon as I put it up, I just realized it was such a mistake. Because it just looks so weird and arrogant. I don't know if you've ever seen that MTV Cribs episode of Mariah Carey where she goes to this room and she reads all the notes from her fans. It was just like, oh, what have I become, man?
然后我当时想，把这些挂起来做装饰应该挺不错的。于是我就把它们挂在我家里的一个房间里，结果刚一挂上去，我立马就意识到这是一个天大的错误。因为看起来实在太诡异、太自大狂了。我不知道你们有没有看过玛丽亚·凯莉上MTV《明星豪宅秀》（MTV Cribs）的那期节目，她走到一个房间里，朗读粉丝写给她的所有便条。当时那种感觉就是：天哪，我到底变成什么样的人了？
I know, right? I know, I know. I know, right? What a house that was. But at least we have you, and it's you and Chris Riddingham as well, is that true? That's right, yeah, he's a CBS commentator. He's a funny guy and he knows loads about football. Now, this would be your sidekick. He is, he's my co-host.
对啊，没错！我懂，我懂。对啊，没错！那可真是一栋豪宅啊。不过好歹我们有你，而且还有克里斯·惠丁海姆，对吧？没错，是的，他是CBS的解说员。他是个很有趣的家伙，而且对足球了如指掌。所以，这将会是你的黄金搭档。对，他就是我的联合主持人。
To continue with the late night show analogy. Yeah, yeah. He's basically, he's got all the knowledge and we're just going to kind of riff and then we'll have kind of celeb guests and it's going to basically be, it's the dream job for me. Will are you going to be the first guest? I'm hoping I will be a guest if they'll ask me. You're waiting for someone to reach out? Well yeah man.
延续深夜秀的比喻。对，对。他基本上包揽了所有的专业知识，而我们俩就负责天马行空地瞎扯，然后我们会请来各种明星嘉宾，基本上——这绝对是我梦寐以求的工作。威尔，你会成为他的首位嘉宾吗？如果他们邀请我的话，我希望自己能去当个嘉宾。你还在等别人来联系你？对啊，老兄。
Well I can reach out. Right? Well, I don't want to be presumptuous and think that they want to fucking talk to me. I would love to talk to you. Would you? There it is. We have our first booking. Have you ever played at Hanfield?
那我来联系他。好不好？好吧，我可不想自作多情，以为他们他妈的想跟我聊天。我很乐意跟你聊聊。真的吗？瞧这不就成了。我们有了第一位预定嘉宾。你在安菲尔德球场踢过球吗？
That would be my first question. I've never played. I've been on the pitch. Save it for the show. Save it for the show. Yeah. Yeah, don't get... yeah, you don't want to go. I've seen Mo Salah getting a rub down after a match. Okay.
这会是我的第一个问题。我从来没踢过。不过我踏上过草坪。留着到节目里说吧。留着到节目里说。对。对，别急着……对，你可别去。我亲眼见过穆罕默德·萨拉赫在赛后接受按摩。好吧。
And I had... Was that at the change of room or did you just... That was at the hotel. ...you got a really good telescope. No, no, no, that was... Through the blinds. Just outside like that, yeah, yeah. This one fucking truck wouldn't move and I finally got a glimpse.
那是更衣室里，还是你只是……那是在酒店里。……你带了望远镜吧。不，不，不，那是……透过百叶窗。就像那样在窗外偷看，对，对。有辆大卡车死活不肯挪开，我最后好不容易才瞅见一眼。
I got the fucking angle I wanted. I had Darwin Nunez walk by and basically give me a high five holding a towel and he was just in a towel. I mean, some pretty cool... Hank, were you in the changing room? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Right after the match. That must have felt so awkward. It was very awkward.
我终于找到了想要的拍摄角度。我看到达尔文·努涅斯从旁边走过，手里拿着一条毛巾，顺便跟我击了个掌，而且他当时只围了一条毛巾。我的意思是，有些画面真的很酷……亨克，你当时在更衣室里吗？对，对，对，对。就在比赛结束后。那感觉一定尴尬极了。确实非常尴尬。
What do you do in a situation... Because basically they're all having a shower and you know... Just waiting with a stack of towels. Does anyone want a Lucasate or a Gatorade or a Powerbar? Would you like a Powerbar? I tell you what they didn't appreciate was my boner. Yeah, exactly. Oh, that's what you should have done.
在这种情况下你该怎么办……因为基本上他们都在冲澡，然后你知道的……手里拿着一叠毛巾在一旁干等。有人想要卢卡斯乃（Lucozade）或者佳得乐，还是能量棒？你想来根能量棒吗？我跟你说，他们最不爽的就是看到我的勃起。对，没错。哦，你应该那样做的。
You should have got in the shower. You should have got in the shower with them. I know, I should have. That would have... Now you would have wanted to have me as a guest if I'd been in the shower. You should have got in the shower with them. I know I should have. Now you would have wanted to have me as a guest if I'd been in the shower. I guess I would. But there's so much to talk about. The football, as you said, Russell,
你当时就该直接冲进淋浴间。你应该跟他们一起洗澡的。我知道，我早就该这么做了。那才叫……这样一来，你要是洗完澡出来，就会求着让我当你的嘉宾了。你应该跟他们一起洗澡的。我知道我早就该这么做了。这样一来，我要是洗完澡出来，你就会求着让我当你的嘉宾了。我想我确实会的。不过有太多事情可以聊了。足球，正如你所说，拉塞尔，
it's so endless, the stories. And that's what drew me into football, how I became it. I love sports, but I became a football fan once I started to understand the stories of who this manager was, who this player was and stuff, that's actually what... And I started watching all the docu-series about the various things. So we want to bring on goalists, kind of bring listeners in so they can start to understand the culture of football, of soccer, right?
它的故事简直无穷无尽。这也是当初把我吸引进足球世界的原因，我是怎么入坑的。我一直很喜欢体育，但自从我开始去理解那些足球经理的故事、球员的故事之后，我就真正成了一个足球迷。这其实就是……我开始观看各种关于足球的纪录系列片。所以我们想在《进球者》里把听众带进来，让他们开始领略足球的文化，英式足球的文化，对吧？
That's exactly it, yeah. I need that. I'm actually excited about that. Yeah, me too. So it premieres, it premieres, guys, when? 19th of September. 19th of September. 19th of September. Thursday, September 19th and two new episodes released each week
完全正确，对。我太需要这个了。我对这个节目其实兴奋得不得了。对，我也是。所以它首播的日子是——各位，是什么时候？9月19日。9月19日。9月19日。9月19日，星期四，每周会推出两集新节目，
every Monday and Thursday, which is good. It's going to be great. Russell Howard and Chris Whittingham, yeah. Great. That's right. If you ever find yourself in England, I've got two season tickets to Liverpool. Have you?
分别在每周一和周四更新，这挺不错的。节目一定会非常精彩。拉塞尔·霍华德和克里斯·惠丁海姆，太棒了。没错了。如果你哪天发现自己身在英国，我手里有两张利物浦的赛季季票。真的吗？
I would love to bring you along. I think that's more for me and Sean, not you Will. Go ahead. No, no, I could probably get another one. But to be honest, we'll be down in the showers. Yeah, it will be. Just getting them ready. Just getting the temperature ready.
我很乐意带你一起去。我觉得那是留给我和肖恩的，不是留给你的，威尔。你继续。不，不，我大概能搞到另一张票。但说实话，我们到时候会直接泡在浴室里。对，没错。就负责准备毛巾。负责把水温调好。
Anybody want to get ready? Yeah, exactly. Just putting your elbow in. Yep, that's fine. That's good. That's so good. Very nice. Russell, thank you so much for your time.
有人要准备洗澡吗？对，没错。把手肘伸进去试个水温。行，水温刚好。太棒了。非常棒。拉塞尔，非常感谢你抽空作客。
We're so excited for Goalus. It's going to be great. Goalus! Thanks for it. I'm really looking forward to it. Nice, thank you so much for your time. We're so excited for Goalus. It's going to be great. Goalus! Thanks for it. I'm really looking forward to it. Nice to meet you. You too. Cheers.
我们对《进球者》充满期待。节目一定会大火的。《进球者》！谢谢你们。我真的非常期待。太棒了，非常感谢你抽空作客。我们对《进球者》充满期待。节目一定会大火的。《进球者》！谢谢你们。我真的非常期待。很高兴认识你。我也是。保重。
September 19th. Alright, chaps. Have a good day. See you later. Thanks, Russ. See you, buddy. Bye bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
9月19日。好了，伙计们。祝你们有美好的一天。回头见。谢谢你，拉塞尔。再见，老兄。拜拜拜。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意一句话即可发表评论。